Yeah.
Well,
well,
well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
All right,
Jean,
we're back.
Oh,
we're,
we're recording now.
We're recording.
Yeah.
It's exciting.
I like your shirt.
You're very fancy today.
Yeah.
Well you,
you usually dress like a slob and so I'm dressed like a slob.
Hoping that you'd be dressed like a slob.
Why do you say that?
I don't dress like us,
but you've got a nice shirt on it now I feel like I look like a dick.
Then you look all nice.
I feel like you always want your deck.
Me?
Yeah.
Really?
But that's only because I'm trying to match your low level of attire.
That's the,
I really addressed that for.
Yeah.
I was just remembering one time you did,
we did this episode and you were wearing your underwear and we were recording
video.
Yeah.
But you couldn't see it hotter.
But I could see it.
I bet anchors do that.
You know,
on TV.
I think they do.
I think I'm seeing something where a guy stood up and it was like denim wearing
shorts or something.
Yeah.
No shoes.
Farts.
They don't care.
It's a desk show.
You're at the desk cares.
Are we going to do dates at the top?
We already did them,
Babe.
Oh we did?
Yeah.
Sorry.
I like when you get mad at me like God stupid.
No,
it's a stupid question,
right when I hear you.
We already did it,
Babe.
Like you,
I feel like you're going to hit me or Ah,
God gave me how much do you hate me and my fantasies?
How much do you hate me when I fucking fantasy?
When I get something wrong like that?
What does it do to you?
It upsets me on a fucking,
just at my core.
Yeah.
Why?
Cause it's such a dumb question
because it was,
it was a silly question to ask.
Dumb.
Yeah.
Stupid.
And then in your head,
do you,
are you like so stupid bitch or is that just my,
you know,
that's your internal dialogue.
You always kind of make up insults that aren't I do.
I always assume when I upset you that you were like,
you stupid fucking dumped that.
I never say that.
And you,
what do you say that,
but what do you say?
It has to be some variant of that guy's a still,
she's so stupid.
I was single.
Wish I was on Tinder.
Like dig.
Does it go there?
No,
it's not.
It's not that,
it's not that.
It's just,
you know,
uh,
I wonder how much longer she'll live.
Stuff like that.
Yeah.
Like do you fantasize about the psych at wife for just being single?
Second.
Third,
yeah.
All of them.
Would you remarry?
No.
Why?
Why go through this again?
I don't want to do this again.
Would you have a second family?
That's the craziest part.
When people do that.
Yeah,
I would,
you have more babies with another woman in another state,
so they don't like run into each other.
Yeah.
And then when you're on,
you're like,
I'm doing no one of them.
Right.
Do you tell her?
I think I can tell no one.
Because you're like,
I'm going to have no idea.
Right.
I'm going to Denver again.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
You have to open up that second company in Denver and you're always in Denver
every other week,
every other weekend.
Or maybe you become a truck driver.
That's kind of the easiest way to do truck driver.
Yeah.
Until that trucking company,
he's like,
you got a new route.
You got to go every week to San Francisco,
and you're like,
oh,
but then you start a third family,
I guess.
Yeah.
You gotta be real tight with money.
Oh my gosh.
Two families to support or,
and then if you get up to three,
that's bananas.
Yeah.
That's too hard.
And they're always like,
damn.
Yeah,
you travel a lot.
And a guy I know.
Yeah.
Yup.
That's how it goes.
I know.
Well,
let's start the show.
Okay,
let's do it,
man.
Let's go.
Ready?
Yeah.
And Jake,
go
touching on the water
in the water.
This is the Orange County sheriff's department.
Be advised.
State parks is asking us to make an announcement to let you know you were paddle
boarding decks to approximately 15 great white sharks.
They're advising that you exit the water and a calm manner.
Sure.
The sharks are as close as the surf line.
Thank you for your cooperation.
Randy.
Don't bring anyone loving to this.
Well,
welcome to your mom's house,
Christina.
So ridiculous.
You're
turning into such an angry dad.
What's so funny?
Like this morning Ellis was splashing water outside of the sink because he plays
in the sink and then he likes to do this thing where he splashes outside because
then we get mad and then we pull them out.
Like it's a game we all play now.
Yeah.
And he spilled water like he does every time.
And you're like God damn and Ellis.
Yeah.
Dammit.
What did I tell you about the water?
Leave subspecies scare him.
I was like,
oh,
that's such a dad mode.
Like you went to full dad mode on him.
Well yeah.
I mean he was spilling a lot of water.
Come a got,
damn it.
I have a feeling I'm going to be a lot of God damn it.
Oh,
the kids are going to hear that all the time.
Yeah.
That's what dads do though.
They just show their rage.
You gotta be angry.
Someone
where do you get a lot of pent up anger and then it comes out?
Yeah.
It's little things like this,
Huh?
Yeah.
It's all like for you,
but then it comes out to other things.
I figured,
I figured
like you don't want to,
we don't want to confront whatever annoys you in the moment.
And then it stores it and stores that was doors up and then you get mad at the
kids filling water.
Right.
Or like Christina had forgot that we did the dates.
All righty.
Oh,
so angry.
Yeah.
Um,
this is terrifying.
We saw this clip and I,
I've swam in those waters.
I think I learned to surf longs waters.
Yeah.
And the crazy,
the Orange County sheriff's department.
Oh my God.
Imagine your paddle boarding out there.
No,
they fly over first.
You notice them hovering over it.
Maybe somebody who's in trouble out here,
and then they go,
hey,
you don't be alarmed.
There's this great white sharks calmly take yourself to the,
to the shore.
How did that guy even cut,
contain his emotions enough to be that calm?
The guy saying it.
He kind of laughed.
I thought at one point she's like,
ah,
I hear a little,
there's a little pitch change where he says calm manner and it sounds like he's
almost laughing cause he knows,
oh my God,
look at the fucking size of that.
Keen of them dude
asking us to make an announcement to let you know you were paddle boarding next
to approximately 15 great white sharks.
They're advising that you exit the water right here.
Listen.
And a calm manner.
Yeah.
Thank you for your cooperation,
man.
If I heard that shit and why is it a water be paddling fast as fuck?
No,
it's heavily populated.
Great White Sharks.
Please do not get to the water.
Fuck
me.
How about you guys drop a line down and pluck that person out of the water like
you're in the fucking,
they do that.
That's how they rescue people drowning or far out you.
They just drop a line down and then the lifeguard jumps out and gets you out.
I'd say,
let's do that instead of the announcement over and over.
Let's take decisive action.
No,
I when I was on road rules,
nope.
No,
I trained when I trained,
I trained with the Australian Coast Guard.
I did,
um,
uh,
Bondai beach and they taught us how to do that.
That was one of the missions.
How you,
you get lowered by the rope and then you pluck the person out.
So what's your theory on why they didn't do that?
I don't know.
Laziness.
You think they're just being lazy?
Yeah.
I think they wanted a cool video to submit to youtube.
Get those hits.
I don't know.
You know,
that's not true.
Who knows?
You
know,
it's not true.
It's not.
Yeah.
That would be terrifying though.
Oh my God.
Great.
Why egg whites?
Whites right there too.
Yeah.
Fuck man.
Fuck.
It's nuts.
There's a lot of them.
God,
there's got to be nothing fucking scarier.
I mean,
I think if I heard that announcement like as soon as he fucking started that
announcement,
the first moment
touching on the water,
the water,
this is the Orange County sheriff's department be advised,
state parks is asking us to make an announcement to liquor paddleboarding next
to approximately 15 great white shark,
great white sharks that you exit the water and a calm manner
and then just pools of diarrhea coming out the back of my shorts.
No.
Do you think that would attract the sharks to problem or repelled for panel?
The show,
the shit.
There'd be a new,
it's just a new tastes.
New Smell to them and they don't fucking,
yeah.
Plus what you eat.
It's all ground up in and out Burger and what?
Whatever trash you've been eating on the run late and trash.
Although I did have horrible meals and Eugene.
Yeah,
I heard that's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
Sickle cell and I went up to um,
Eugene and back to Portland,
Oregon and Portland shows were really fun,
man.
We could not get a good meal.
It's so weird.
I hate that we went to Eugene.
We went,
I don't want to trash the places,
you know,
because it's like they weren't like egregiously trying to ruin our time.
Yeah.
He just wasn't good.
We went to a place for lingerie,
like this is fucking dog shit.
What did you order?
Well,
he had,
he had a shrimp cocktail and there was salad shrimp.
Ah,
the ones that are not,
I would say one quarter of one inch.
You know those melons?
Yeah.
And then he ordered some oysters for us.
The Louise.
Hey,
where did you guys go with it?
And I want to say no.
It was a nice,
it was there.
They were like,
it's a good restaurant and it was fucking terrible.
Okay.
Then we went to,
uh,
I forget another place after show.
It was all right.
And then we,
uh,
breakfast the next morning at the hotel.
I interject.
It was no fucking up.
Breakfast is hard.
It sucks.
Yeah.
Then we went to Portland and we did have something good.
You know,
you can always get something good in Portland,
Oregon,
Portland,
amaze for eating.
Where do we go?
We've got it.
Meet.
Rattle.
Yeah.
Such good food.
And meat rattled too.
Yeah.
We were like,
this is,
this is our first good meal was in Portland.
It's terrible.
There's nothing worse than bad road food.
Cause then with the road food comes to road shifts.
Oh.
So then you asshole hurts everything.
So hungry and miserable.
Tired as fuck.
But thanks everybody that came out.
That was crazy.
I ended up doing four shows at revolution hall.
Right.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
Thank you everybody.
Yeah.
Lots of genes there.
Um,
I wanted to point out that um,
you and Ryan are both in a special category now.
Yeah.
You're both no longer regular people
shoes.
No,
I uh,
since I had a child,
my back's messed up,
my feet messed up.
I have SCIATICA and I started to wear orthopedic shoes.
Yeah.
Now not all of them look good.
There's a brand called Vionic that I've been into and they make really good
looking orthopedic shoes.
And I said this is an unpaid sponsor.
Yeah,
it is.
Yeah.
Cause if you,
if you have Sciatica,
give like spinal misalignments or whatever,
I have one leg shorter than the other.
It's been that way my whole life.
But for some reasons that I had a kid,
my hips got all messed up and everything.
So it's gotten bad.
Here's what a,
yeah,
that's sickle cell wore these,
I have the same ones but slip on the single dad or support sevens.
Those are good balance.
And he said they come in four colors only.
Yeah.
It's like these all maroon.
Uh,
I think beige and one other,
but he said they completely changed the way his,
his back and felt,
cause I'll get women's shoes are horribly unsupportive if not damaging to our
feet.
The ballet flats or can't even do it.
Balances.
By the way.
I have those.
I have those exact except slip on from when I was preggers.
It's terrible.
I put these
new ones,
those look orthopedic too.
Some people really like them.
Some people fucking hated them.
I couldn't believe how many people,
everyone's an asshole.
Why those for bicycling?
No,
no they're not.
It's for bicycling.
They're not,
are they for running?
Are a specific sport?
No,
no.
They're just total like a,
what do they call,
you know,
social shoes?
Like they're just walking around shoes.
They're not the streetwear.
Yeah.
But a man,
they got a lot of people like a look at this terrible,
um,
them shits is due to
someone called these dad shoes.
These are like,
yeah,
this super exclusive undefeated Collabo with Adidas and they're like,
dad,
she was like,
we talked about,
can I tell you there's a fine line between cool sneakers and then too much going
on to make them look supportive and then that's where it goes into a dad
sneaker.
Why,
why they're saying that?
This is just my theory is when you've got a lot of different hooks and things
and sure it when it starts to look like a hiking shoe.
I see what you're saying.
Bicycle shoe.
Yeah.
Been see it that way it loses,
it's cool cause I still think there are,
I think this is a bunch of nerds on my fucking Instagram.
I have no style whatsoever.
I don't know.
I kind of agree with,
I'm sorry.
I think those are a little dad support.
Yeah,
really.
I Dunno.
I think,
yeah,
I think there's a bunch of tools.
A picture of my shoes,
my new orthopedics and we'll see who like who they like better.
I'm clearly the shoe champion if send it.
You did send in those uh,
sent back those terrible ones,
right?
Well cause I ordered them and I got four pairs and I try them on for you because
look,
let's keep it real.
You're the one that looks at me all the time.
I'm going to want to look decent.
Yeah.
So you okayed two of them and then two,
you were like,
no.
Did I have shut down too?
I thought I shut this.
Sorry.
You shut down one pair.
The other one didn't.
They're too big.
They were hot pink.
Slip on sneaks with like a strap,
like a Mary Jane Strap on top.
And you did not like that.
Look,
what would,
what about that shoe were you not interested in a photo of them so he could
really break it down?
You can Google it and bionic slip ons.
Hot Pink,
v I.
O.
N.
I.
C bionic slip on women's sneaker pink.
Hot Pink.
Try that one.
Okay.
Now they also make a cool ass live ons.
I got a gray pair,
like suede looking.
Those are dope.
And then I want to,
yeah,
those are,
that's it.
See,
I just don't feel like they were that bad.
These are like,
you know,
this reminds me of um,
uh,
um,
somewhere in Europe and then some,
a 78 year old,
a American woman who's on a,
it was with a tour group.
[inaudible].
She's like,
I haven't been back here in 50 years.
And she walks around the corner wearing these and I'm like,
oh,
that's nice old lady sneakers you got on.
Yeah,
because she's like,
if I didn't have him,
I'd just collapsed to the ground in pain.
Is She wearing khaki?
Cool.
Lots.
Yeah.
No,
these are terrible.
I thought those were cute.
Now try the blue color.
Do you like the blue ones better?
Is it not a color thing?
Oh,
it's not a color.
It's the style.
Black as fuck old lady style.
Yeah.
But I need sneakers that are,
have art that have arch support.
Tom's got a cube hunting,
but right now I have,
I have the new balance ones.
The,
they're identical to what?
Sickle cell.
Where's,
I'm not even joking.
Those are terrible.
You should see them when he had jeans on.
We gotta get him some bionics.
I know.
And telling you it's all about that arch support.
Yeah.
Because my feet will hurt if I just wear regular flats.
Can't do it.
Yeah.
Forget it.
It's crazy.
It's part of aging,
you know.
I know.
So your fetal hurt.
My feet will hurt my back.
Sadeka it all flares up.
It's really bad.
Yeah.
That's the fun of being 40.
So we also went on a mommy's night out at TMN total mom night.
We spent the night in a hotel like we do once a month.
Yup.
And we ate a lot of bad food.
Don't tell our trainer.
No,
don't tell her.
And we also relax in bed.
We watched a shitty movie.
Then we watch things stupid.
Yeah,
it was,
it started that,
um,
what's a great actor?
He was on breaking bad.
The young kid on the,
I don't know his name,
Blake.
Blake lively.
Blake lively,
the guy from breaking bad and it was a cool premise,
but it just went to shit.
So many movies just go to shit man.
They just shit the fucking bed.
And um,
this one did too.
The premise was that his girlfriend just disappeared.
Like they were together for four years and then one day she disappears.
So what happens to her?
And then he starts looking for,
and you're not going to like all the answers you get,
that kind of thing.
So you're start,
you get involved and you get invested,
but the reveals or are just stupid in the end was kind of lame,
super lame.
Super.
Then I also,
you know what disappointed is not,
I mean you can say that this is a sexist I guess,
but I don't buy her being what they said she was.
In other words,
it's not that I don't believe any woman could do that.
I don't believe that actress,
is that,
do you understand what I'm saying?
I understand what you're saying.
Like she's not,
it's not believed.
It wasn't tough enough.
In a weird,
she wasn't,
come on,
she was just like a cute blonde.
She wasn't like a tough,
tough blonde.
I mean,
yeah,
it's completely unbelievable.
What about a lady doctor?
Do you buy that?
It depends.
Where is she from?
Right.
What about like a lady scientist?
Is that totally ridiculous too?
Yeah.
Like a not attractive one.
Sure.
Like Grey's anatomy with,
what's her name?
The blonde actress?
I Dunno.
Heigel Katherine Heigl scientists that she was a doctor.
No,
of course not.
No.
What should she be to 25 to two 40.
Why large is that you're saying now?
Why should she be occupation wise?
What Katherine Heigl that you would believe that she,
what she does for a living in a movie?
I'm saying,
Oh,
I'm drinker.
Yes.
Oh No,
that's disgusting.
Real estate real estate secretary,
secretary.
That's not for hot checks anymore.
Oh,
it's not my 50 flight attendant.
Um,
but gate agent,
gate agent at the airport?
No.
What could she be?
I mean,
I'm a,
I'm of the school of thought that she could be a scientist,
a doctor or a lawyer.
No two attractive care.
Yeah.
Okay.
So your theory is that attractive people don't go into professions either.
Gender.
Really,
that's not true.
We have attractive people that we professionally deal with.
Don't get us into trouble now.
Okay.
No,
we don't.
Okay.
We have really good looking,
uh,
professionals that we deal with now.
Come on now.
Okay.
You know,
that's not true.
I mean,
I'm not saying there's not any out there,
but that's for the most part,
you know,
uglier.
People have to strive to make a name for themselves.
They have to work in life.
So I feel like you usually see ugly looking people in.
Move on.
Let's go on to other topics,
but I'm totally right about that.
I don't know.
No,
I do know.
It's not like a,
it's not like you don't see supermodels at the hospital.
No.
You don't see many,
uh,
doctors.
That's true.
Now Watch,
we're going to get a bunch of emails from people who are like,
I was a model of,
no,
I'm a scientist feeling kind of damage to send pictures.
Right.
I a borderline model,
Lachlan.
Marginally attractive.
Our a plus size model pig.
Yeah,
yeah.
With your big old dirty fucking ditch hanging down donkey tits went,
Oh,
speaking of movies.
So we also were trying to keep the family tradition going in our,
our night a away of ordering an adult film and the hotel,
well,
let's just to say it's a tradition that started,
we didn't start the fire,
but it started on us and the Dominican Republic when we stayed at a resort that
played hardcore pornography on our television and it was like,
wow,
does everybody get this in their room?
No,
no.
Cause we asked,
it was just us and we watched a lot of hardcore stuff that week in Dr and then
it got us to kind of getting used to that.
Now it's hard to go back.
It's true.
It's like eating at five star restaurant and then you know,
you can't go into Mcdonald's every day after that.
So now when we stay in a hotel or go into vacation,
we like to order it on TV that Dr please.
It was around the clock nonstop.
I was in a hotel in Europe went through,
it was like that too and stand somewhere where it was like 24,
seven you get hard core pornography.
Yeah.
And in this place it was obviously you order a movie,
right?
Or you can order like the,
the four hour package and all that stuff or hours.
It's a thing about with Dr is that like your kid could just turn the channel and
find that it wasn't on restricted times.
You know,
it was channel 69
we just kinda cool cause then you can explain two things.
Your kid at once.
Sure.
There's 69 and this is hardcore porn,
but this was a babies are made.
Yeah.
We uh,
we looked through the titles.
That was not one of them.
Yeah.
No,
but we were trying to figure out like,
wow,
I said,
baffle,
snore.
Geez.
I'm trying to figure out what's the,
uh,
what's the one we want to watch the theme for the night?
Could it be,
yeah.
I mean a lot to choose from.
There's a lot of male stuff is very popular.
It's very popular.
But we also found that a new genre,
not new,
but a genre has become the head multiple films prevalent and that was Harry.
Harry are seeing four or five titles in a hotel.
It's a trend.
Yeah,
it's picked up.
It was like my Harry teen and my wife's Harry Bush.
Every Carol's yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
I,
my theory on the hairy stuff,
uh,
is that that place probably accommodates what's popular by the client for the
clientele.
So either it's like maybe they have a lot of Asian businessmen who were in a
hairy stuff.
Maybe it's Europeans who come over and like hairy stuff.
Do you categorize those to the Asians are very,
uh,
they're anti specific kinky stuff.
They like,
you know,
there are vending machines that sell dirty panties in Japan school girl thing.
Yeah.
So they have particular kinks nationally.
I'm sure we do too.
I just don't know them.
I don't know.
Like what do we like,
I think we're obsessed with mothers milfs which is,
which is just code for over 30 like it's not,
it doesn't necessarily,
right.
It doesn't mean you're a mom.
It just means your over teen?
Yeah.
It's either teen or MILF.
It's super weird.
So I'm,
I'm going to go with Asian because it's because they are generally hair less or
less hairy than white people.
So I'm thinking they might be the new kink.
I don't know.
What do you,
what's your,
who's who's buying the hairy stuff?
I see.
I think it's less specific to them specifically as much as it is.
Um,
just that's where the trend is period.
Wow.
I think so.
Yeah.
So you're saying that that's just the genre or all over the world,
so that people,
I mean maybe not all over the world,
but I'm saying that overall,
I think that John was probably just popular at the moment.
Sure.
It's exciting news for me.
This
is Christ,
this guy.
The
crazy
luck here.
Okay.
Would you rather and prompt you or would you rather feast on this guy's big
nips?
Oh,
oh.
Or you're doing pup play with your new friends.
It's not sexual.
You're just wearing the costumes.
I think I'd have to wear a costume if Haley
eyes water.
Well,
part of that wouldn't be pleasant for you.
I don't want like him talking about it all the time.
Oh my God.
And I remember his big hang like thick.
Yeah.
Like what does it like body dysmorphic nipples.
They're not,
you know.
Yeah.
He clearly played with them a lot or stretched him like he fucked them up so
they could make videos like this.
What a noble cause to destroy your nipples so that you can make videos for other
perverts to look at.
Oh God.
Yeah.
So,
okay.
So we had the titles.
There was Harry,
but then there was,
yeah,
the one that really caught our attention really caught our attention.
I'm really disappointed we didn't watch it though.
Can I say what?
Can I tell him the title?
Sure.
It was fuck my triple d.
Slash.
Wife.
Yeah,
right.
I was like,
perfect.
Silly.
I got one right here next to me.
Yeah.
Well if you were doing movies behind my back.
Well,
you know,
of course,
you know what I really like about that is that it incorporates two genres.
There's the big boobs.
Yeah.
And also the cuckolding thing of like humiliate me by fucking my web and liquid.
Triple the sweat.
Other popular genre.
Yeah,
that's a big one.
Yeah.
Well I just googled that,
um,
that title and I found some other ones I found I let him fuck my slot wife.
Please Bang.
My wife tripled the fuck me.
Yeah.
My friend fucks my wife and comes in her.
What I like about these titles is there's no mystery.
There's no,
no,
nope.
There's no veiling.
What?
What's happening here?
Yeah.
It's kind of Nice.
Your wife.
I just,
nothing man.
Is it maybe bang my,
I'm,
I am.
I might be bang my triple d slot wide.
Really?
Yeah.
Okay.
F might be too harsh.
It can I please turn the air up?
I'm freezing.
Oh,
it's fine.
It's distracting.
My legs are freezing.
My white wife is used by three black class.
No,
no.
What are you doing man?
I'm so cold.
You have a sweatshirt on.
I have my,
I don't have socks on.
Oh,
come on man.
You're ruined everything.
You ruined everything.
What are you raising it to?
What'd you put it on?
maybe we have heat lamps in here,
man.
I can't even think I'm so distracted.
He's,
you seriously ruined this.
How did I ruin that?
You just did right now.
That's fine.
You don't even feel it.
I wonder.
I'm going to lower it.
If it gets too hot,
we'll just turn the air on.
That's all.
God dammit.
You need your balls,
milk.
You're so aggressive to them.
So anyways,
we didn't order that film it because it also brought me back to the time we went
on a cruise with my parents.
Yeah.
My whole family actually.
And we decided we want to order a movie then.
And we did.
Yeah.
And on this cruise you could order a film.
And it was a soft core film.
Yeah.
It was so disappointed.
Ever seen that before?
Like you'd pay to watch softcore so dumb.
So after we've fast forwarded through it and realize what it was,
I called a guest relations and the Filipino guy was like,
yes.
I said,
I ordered this movie and,
and there's,
there's no penetration.
And he goes,
wow.
I said,
I wanted hardcore.
I want to see it going and out.
And
so he
checked with his manager and he was like,
okay,
we will refund.
No,
we checked it.
We asked him,
are there any hardcore ones I don't want to see softcore it's a waste of my time
and money.
So then he put us on hold and he asked his manager if there are any hardcore
films,
Bang,
my triple D's slept peg wipe.
I have such a soft spot for that lady cause you know,
she's like,
you know what we're here to do.
Just go.
Yeah.
She was like,
come on.
It's like I gotta pick my kid up from school three quits abating.
Do Bro.
Yeah.
I mean cause this fucking come on.
Yeah,
you can tell that she's just like,
yeah,
it's horrible.
Let's pick up the pace a little bit.
It's horrible.
Um,
back to your thing about attracted people.
I was thinking about it.
You're right that a lot of them become like trainers,
personal trainers.
I see him.
It's a,
it's an exercise in their own vanity.
There's a trainer,
my friend Mary Lynn showed me a picture on Instagram and I was like,
this guy's like perfect.
Like you ever see somebody who's so attractive,
just perfect that your,
I can't even look at your,
it makes me uncomfortable.
Instagram's the place to find them by the way.
They've found their,
uh,
their place in this social media world.
Like this Instagram,
you just like if you open your explore page,
sometimes they're just beautiful people and you go there and it's like,
it's not anyone of like any known,
uh,
field or talent.
They're just like,
I'm incredibly good looking and I'm sharing it with all of you.
A mess.
That hole that's there for them.
Do they get paid?
Do you think if you build up enough followers,
you definitely can get paid just for being good looking?
Well,
it's just like that Cameron Dallas boy that we watched the Netflix show about
all those boys,
by the way.
I loved their Instagram feeds because they're all really cute and that's all
they do.
And then they do meet and greets and they make a ton of money.
But here's the best part on Instagram.
You see what they're spending their money on.
Oh,
and right now it's like,
here's my new Lamborghini with the doors that come up or whatever,
like Delorean type.
Here's my,
this place I'm renting right now in the Hollywood hills,
and you're like,
dude,
you're renting like buy a house.
They're renting these really expensive houses.
They're getting ridiculous cars.
They're going on ridiculous vacations.
I'm like,
you're just burning through it.
If I got a little amount of money at 16 what are you going to do so stupid and
feel like I'm going to get this forever?
You don't think that that would ever slow down.
Now I know.
What are they going to do when they turn 30 it's like 30 Oh,
how about when they turned 20 I was going to go away.
Not going to be cute little kids anymore.
Oh my goodness.
What are we doing?
I don't know.
Stuff like this.
Oh,
fuck me.
Fuck me.
Oh yes,
sir.
Yes.
Ah,
yes.
There's $600
were those meet and greets you?
He's make 600,000 in a weekend is Christ.
Could you imagine how painful that is?
That that is such a,
that's also very daunting clip because it's like,
is he liking it or not?
Right down the middle.
Yeah.
There's moments of both feelings.
Here's somebody who is horribly upsetting.
Yeah.
Uh,
God damn it.
This is like,
this pisses me off that this even exists.
This is real.
Traceability is the desire or need to move from being able to be disabled.
It's true choice stones.
Troy.
I got it.
Yeah.
So there is a fucking assholes out there.
Then if you're like,
wait,
what do they want?
No,
just no bad.
Want some form of amputation.
Want Ida Ronan two legs or wanting to,
um,
a number wants to be paralyzed.
Okay.
They have a very specific point at which they want their building to be
paralyzed.
I mean,
okay.
And here are,
you just beat the fuck out of it.
Right.
And do that.
And we're suppose,
here's the thing is that we're supposed to be super tolerant of everybody's
needs and emotional states,
but at what point can we just be like,
you know what?
You're fucking mentally ill.
Yeah.
Okay,
you got problems and you need to go to a see a shrink because your head's fucked
up.
Yeah,
you are.
You're fucking weird.
Why?
Why can't we just call people weird anymore or abnormal?
Hey,
guess what?
Your psychology,
it's abnormal.
You're not normal.
It was a,
it's a pushback on people saying that too much for everything.
Like in other words,
people were told you are not normal if you're gay.
Right,
right,
right.
So then that pushback is that anything,
anything you want is embrace.
You want to,
you want to amputate your arms to feel special and different.
Yeah,
go ahead.
You are a fucking asshole.
A total asshole.
No,
I mean I really,
it enrages me that somebody is going to sign up for that.
Like fuck you know how lucky you are.
Well,
if you're going to amputate your arm,
then donate it to a vet who just had his fucking arms blown off by an IED in
Afghanistan.
Well,
personally spoken to,
looks like it wants to become blind.
I like how empathetic this guy to move with his penis.
Go for it.
Good.
Please.
You don't reproduce.
I need to move away from pathologized and appreciating the,
the,
the feeling wheel distress.
The next beer.
Okay.
What?
Pretending they're not fake case,
but get over it.
It's usually like a leg removed.
Yeah,
but we shouldn't help them know and we shouldn't feel badly for them.
No.
I think we should go back to re pathologizing people.
You need to call them fucking Weirdos and an abnormal,
take him in a room.
You had a couple of fucking baseball bat and give them a real fucking beating
and then afterwards be like,
you still want to lose those limbs.
That's what you should do.
And see if they feel the same way.
Yeah.
You know what?
I think the problem is,
is that we don't institutionalize people anymore.
I think Reagan,
the institutionalized,
a lot of the mentally ill in the 80s and since then,
the thought of putting somebody in a mental hospital is considered very taboo.
But I think you should.
I think there are people who need to be locked up mean what does this guy want
to do?
Celebrate them.
Yeah.
He wants to get some rights.
Here's a whole group of dumb people out there.
They want to do some dumb shit to themselves and we should all be there to help
support and talking about why we have to support every stupid thing that exists.
So fucking random shit.
You don't have to support some stuff is this is wrong.
I mean imagine the person listening to this who was of who it went to fight for
our country and it has her arms and legs blown off and a sitting in and
listening to this fucking,
exactly.
That's what I'm saying was like people who have been in accidents and wars
stupid and they're like,
yeah,
it's been a real thrill that this happened and you want this to happen.
Yeah,
fuck you.
Fuck you.
And your stupid arm
and your dad cutting
barely very catholic.
The secret
prison.
Yeah.
So number amputation was the only way forward.
I'm hearing though is that they want to do it.
He hasn't said that like,
and then they did it.
You realize that good doctors going to voluntarily,
no,
I want them to do it in their fucking backyards.
Like,
I want to hear the story of that.
You know what?
That's a great idea is if you get it,
do it.
You gotta do it.
You got to get like a wooden,
yeah.
What is that?
Just like a cutoff tree.
A stump in the backyard and the acts,
and if you can do it,
it's yours.
You get to do it.
No,
and I want to make youtube videos that are like,
I want to,
yeah.
Yeah.
You got to have to have a,
a horrible are hilarious segment CFF.
We laughed.
All hilarious.
As far as I'm concerned for these assholes.
Most people love the loop.
These feelings.
Well,
can't they just stay feelings though?
Can we just hit the society needs to appreciate it too.
It does.
However,
strange exam,
yes.
Yeah.
Isn't beyond the Pale to allowing people to align with how they feel.
No.
Can I say also the other problem with today's society is that just because you
feel something,
it doesn't mean you have a legitimate right to act on every fucking impulse.
I know feelings.
A lot of feelings.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's like these people really feel feeling,
I feel a lot of ways too.
I did too.
You just fucking sit on those fields.
Right.
Are you sublimate those feelings through healthier outlets?
So maybe,
okay.
I want to be an MPC.
Well maybe how about not coming arm off,
but maybe I do art work about a amputees where I work with people with the,
you know,
why don't you,
uh,
Dan up for a Jujitsu school,
see if they'll break your fucking arm.
Like,
just stay bad at it and then yeah,
it will happen as for the best guy every week and just be like,
arm me,
bro.
Just see if he can just keep cracking that shit.
Yeah.
Maybe that'll feel good.
Go to a few Klan rallies.
Yeah.
Um,
did you go to the Klan Rally?
Well,
I'm just saying like an La and get the shit be naughty or just wear like a Trump
shirt in a la in la,
you know what I mean?
Do something stupid.
Okay.
Yeah.
Speaking of raging,
it is horrible.
Are hilarious.
This is one that came in.
Oof.
I don't know if I can even handle this
one.
What just happened?
What was that?
What is that?
What?
I'm not looking,
I'm not real.
When I came out,
when I came out,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
Oh God.
I can't even look at that.
I don't know.
This is not a good one.
It's not hilarious saying what happened.
Oh No,
I want to see it.
Yeah.
He tied a rope to his balls and then jumped in.
I know what it is that what it was?
I don't know what he did.
Everything that I don't like it.
Oh my God.
Oh God.
Dude is not came out this if you just fucking sick.
I'm leaving.
Look at that guy.
He's like,
I'm leaving,
dude.
That's not cool.
We have an incident,
uh,
at the heritage park and we're probably Virginia.
Uh,
my friend,
he,
he tied a rope.
He tied a rope to himself and then he took off running off a tree.
It was just like,
he was just like fooling around.
Like a bunch of guys were around.
We were just goofing off and he ended up ripping his like his testicle.
Okay.
Well that's a horrible one.
Horrible one.
Okay,
let's take it.
Let's take a breather.
Let's take phone so bad.
Well Great.
That was a full fucking a stoppage.
You actually change clothes.
You were so traumatized.
That blue band is here.
He's adjusting the lighting cause we're having a guest come in soon.
That's the thing that we wanted to announce that um,
we're actually having a guest in studio for the first time in,
well first time here and also the first time and I don't know,
it's gotta be like two years or something.
Yeah.
Cause once we move from the,
from Redondo to house and then we were recording the show next to our son's
nursery.
So we didn't really want to have guests coming in and out of our babies room
essentially.
So it's been awhile.
It's been awhile.
But here we are and we're um,
you know,
we're a,
we're set up for a guest,
but listen,
it turns out that guy,
cause I didn't want to look again.
He tied a rope to his ball bag.
Stupid.
Jumped with the other end,
tied to a tree.
So stupid.
Oh my God.
What happened?
Yeah.
I thought I saw the rope and I was like,
dude,
he did not just,
well the verdict is in horrible are hilarious.
It was fucking horrible.
Horrible.
Wait.
So you didn't even find that.
I thought it was funny in the beginning because I was like,
now what?
What made it not funny for you?
Oh Dude,
any ball related trauma is not funny to me.
I can't,
I can't do it just cause it's a guy.
A guy hurting is nuts.
I can't do it.
I just can't have empathy.
Is that what you're saying in those situations?
You yes.
You're able to put yourself in somebody else's shoes and feel that pain.
Can I tie a rope around your balls?
No.
Just for five
traumatic.
Yeah.
Um,
can I,
can I bring up another topic before we move along?
Sure.
I really want to get this in.
It's super important.
The other day you were calling me from Horrigan and you were on the,
I was on the phone here at home.
You're on the phone and Horrigan and I was talking to you and I had to fess up
and tell you the truth that I was actually sitting on a toilet and making it
brown.
I go,
I'm sorry,
but I gotta go,
I'm taking a shit.
And I realized I couldn't shit with you on the phone.
It didn't feel honest.
And then you said,
I said,
you're never going to believe this.
I'm Browning too.
We were both browning at the same time.
It's a synergy synergy.
Yeah.
And I hit the mute button so that you didn't hear.
Or like when you would start talking,
I would hit mute and then push.
That was my problem with Browning with you is that I would have,
I was afraid you were going to hear my sounds too.
Yeah.
But that was really thoughtful of me.
You agreed on that.
That was really nice and I wish I had thought of that strategy of muting.
I didn't even think of it.
It was crazy to me because I thought I'd snuck in there.
Well,
I did.
We did.
I did too.
We both it and then you're like,
I gotta tell you I'm Brian.
I was like,
oh my mouth dropped.
You believe it.
You were so excited.
You know,
you sell them.
Show emotion or excitement.
I told you I was pregnant.
You're like,
stop
it.
Yeah.
Uh,
somebody send us email.
Speaking of Brown,
is it gross to Brown at a strip club?
No.
I need the Sigora a was to settle.
The situation happened,
I believe only Topdog and buns.
Oh,
me and my dad can provide a balanced perspective on this.
On Friday,
my bus fare and I went to a sleazy strip club to enjoy adult entertainment.
My friend Dan had a couple of beers and he said,
where's the pisser in this joint emotion to the hallway next to the DJ booth.
I turned my attention back to the ladies grinding and they're removing their
clothes.
25 minutes later,
Dan came out of the bathroom.
Apparently Dan decided to take a shit in the bathroom at a strip club.
The savage animal will shit anywhere.
I feel like shitting in a server probably has never allowed.
This is the most Fallon horrid place to relieve oneself.
Here's the question,
is it reasonable to make brown?
I think it's reasonable.
I think so.
And here's why.
Strip clubs are disgusting places to begin with.
Cause that sounds like that's his logic for why not to do it.
And I think that's,
that's odd.
I think if we're,
we're people shit,
uh,
out at night at bars and stuff though,
you're at a bar and you're taking it shit.
That's different.
I think it's weird that you got to shit at that hour.
You know,
I had a friend that every time we go nightclubbing and high school and college,
the minute we get to the club she'd have to,
Shit really does that nerves though,
was that there was nurse and so she would be like,
oh,
taken if I have to go fucking shit at this club.
I mean it's just uncomfortable to shit at a nightclub.
People are waiting in line I think anywhere where there's a long line of people
and it's not really,
no,
I do get by the way,
I guess he's saying,
you know,
there's so many gross dudes and they don't obviously don't care for the
facilities.
But I mean most bathrooms are pretty gross as what I'm saying at the Strip club.
Like guys are obviously pissing and probably jerking off all over those
bathrooms.
But I mean,
you know Shit,
you have to shit.
Yeah,
he's guys gotta take a dump.
But I think anywhere,
well here's an ideal place to shit when there's lots of stalls like a,
you know,
a dodger game,
that's fine.
Airports ideal for shitting cause there's a lot of traffic in and out.
It's quick.
People make quick trips,
you know?
Yeah.
I got a message here that says three 95 audio trouble.
There's trouble in three 95 really?
Let me see this.
Oh,
there was an audio problem.
The episode when Tom Plays an audio clip of Sarah Burns voicemail,
there's a constant howling in my ear.
Stupid.
I know a lot of barking,
scratching,
sniffing,
stupid.
Actually every voicemail from Christina's friends.
I was like a pack of dogs.
Let me know if it's district can be resolved.
Thanks Chris.
Wow.
Now I know what he means.
I know what he means.
Bitsy is in love with blue band.
I don't know what you eat before you come over here,
but this dog can't stop licking him.
Yeah,
his Jiu flavor.
She loves.
Wow.
Two flavors.
What are you eating?
Could fell to fish
or your hands covered and locks before you come over.
How does she love you?
So she just loves him.
Just for a reference.
Uh,
here,
let me see here is
why is this not working?
Why is this not working?
Can I talk about my experiment?
When you're looking for that,
then how did you find it?
So our sun,
it turns out is lactose intolerant.
And you and I did that 23 and me genetic testing a while back and it revealed
that I was lactose intolerant,
which really makes sense because I fucking hate milk.
And every time I would have ice cream,
my stomach would just be wrecked.
I would get gas bubbles like really painful.
Yeah,
I can eat cheese pretty much just fine.
But milk liquid is destroys me.
So my son has it now.
We stopped feeding him regular milk,
he drinks lactose free milk.
And I thought,
yeah,
he's totally fine now.
And I thought to myself,
what if I just tried drinking some milk and just to see if I really have a thing
that I know that's true.
Sometimes you have to verify it.
Yeah.
And so I drank some milk and sure enough,
I shit like three times after and it was really painful.
And so guess what?
I'm lactose intolerant,
but just for milk.
And you already knew this and I knew this,
but I want it to retest the theory here is just to be clear.
Um,
pulled up burns voicemail,
stop it,
stop it.
So stupid.
She's a gorgeous,
here's Mary Lynn.
I can see what he meant.
Maryland rice cub,
also a star of 24 fantastically good looking shot of a,
I want to say her last name and then,
yeah,
I mean,
she's very good looking too.
All my friends are very,
and there you are talking.
Yeah.
I don't know what they,
I mean it sounds like it.
That was the issue,
but I mean it's,
I don't know.
I guess you're saying,
Oh,
my friends are the dog pound.
What?
What kind of lookers do you think you have in your bunch?
Who's in your corner burger or breads or the fattest working comedian out there?
Who's your hot friend collection?
Blue Band.
Yup.
Come on.
Who else do you have now?
Your friends are lovely.
This is,
you know,
we're just your friends or dogs.
Okay.
Ah,
man,
that was fun.
Good time.
But you're,
you're where the dudes,
that guy.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
No,
they're all on attractive.
Your friends are lovely.
They are.
They are lovely.
They're good looking.
Which one of them?
When did you marry up there?
You're there all marriage material.
They are,
yeah.
Yeah,
They've all been married or are married.
Yeah.
They're all marriage material.
Okay.
No,
I would,
I would put it in all of them.
Stop it.
What?
I didn't say,
put it in.
I said Mary,
now I would,
I would finish.
And all of them stop it.
The problem with my friends,
they all got a hungry tits.
And you like sloppers oh no.
Anger.
No,
of course not.
I thought you were into big slops.
I liked his period.
I don't care what size they are.
Yeah.
But you like I'm hanging in mushy purple now or they can be hungry and starving.
It doesn't matter.
I don't care.
Put them in.
Put them,
put them everywhere.
Leave them out.
I like him that you like blondes,
but still,
I mean,
none of them are blind.
If she is the grass on the field.
Stupid.
It's dumb,
Huh?
Cause you can,
it's all pink on the inside.
God,
this.
So,
uh,
here's a dad boner.
This one's pretty fucking great.
This Dad boner decides to go fishing with a drone.
So it was like his own little experiment.
Today we're gonna be doing something that's another internet first and totally
outrageous.
We're going to go fishing.
I love this,
but we're not using worms and we're not in the little Paul.
We were on Lake Champlain and we are going to be trolling with a jitterbug.
Cool.
Let's see how this goes.
So then the drone look,
watch that.
It's fine.
I fish and you just see the fish.
Just I got a fish.
Oh my gosh.
Holy crab apples.
I have apples.
Wait,
he that?
That's just starting.
Oh my gosh.
Crazy that.
That drone caught that though,
right?
I wish you get this excited for me.
Like when you yell for me to come.
I love that.
Look.
It's a huge freaking bat.
Tell me the numbers on my Gopro.
Rolling.
Got Your camera clicks quickly.
You got to hurry up.
I gotta put this down.
Quick,
quick,
quick
turn.
The site here,
the phone sideways.
Marianne's got a newborn in her arm.
Two other little ones and this asshole's excited about his fish is important
that you're doing.
She's like,
could you just fucking help me with these babies right now?
He's stoked about it.
I'd be so mad at him.
I like his Dad Boehner style that ATS is pretty good.
I do wish
you good crab apples.
Cravable I wish you would get excited about anything like that.
I do get excited about what though?
Different things.
Nothing in life is that exciting?
Nothing.
No.
Come on.
I'm never seen you get that gig done.
Anything that's not true.
Never.
Not Excitement.
Excitement's not your thing like personality champs.
Get excited about cabs.
Damn it.
You're just not,
not very excitable or fun or I'm pretty excitable.
No,
never.
You can't think of one time.
Hmm?
You never like jump up and down and like,
oh yeah.
That's so rad.
Yeah.
Watching sports.
Sometimes I get excited.
You.
Yeah.
Okay,
I'll take that back.
Yeah.
Football,
football.
You like that?
It's exciting.
Murder.
You've seen me jump and scream and clap.
Yeah.
Motherfucker.
Angry.
It's like anger,
excitement.
Sometimes they get really excited.
You do?
Yeah.
At that football through.
There you go.
That's a good one.
Okay,
come on.
Don't be nonbinary.
I want to amputate one of my arms.
Fucking assholes,
man.
You've got to respect people,
Tom,
and everybody has a right to have their feelings.
Everyone has right to act on their irrational feelings.
No.
Um,
the other day you're in the kitchen and you pulled your legs up,
you're in your boxer shorts,
you pull your legs up to your ears and then you farted at me.
Yeah.
And I feel like this might be a turning point for us.
And what's way just like in the way of like,
is this it?
Like are we,
are we are brother and sister now?
Like is that,
do you like,
do you even think of me as a woman?
I do.
Of course.
Like somebody that you have sex with or you know that you see me as like an
opposite sex person.
Yeah,
you're totally are.
Yeah.
Okay.
I totally see you as that.
And so if we were recording 12 years ago,
like we just started dating,
would you pull your legs up and Fart at me at the table then?
Or 12 years in the game and you feel like it's in the game?
We're in the game.
I mean,
I actually have I recorded your response when I farted there,
right?
Did I hit it on my phone?
Here you are.
Nope,
I'm a big dog.
I like that.
There I am brother Brussels.
Yeah.
Brussels bark.
So I'm a small dog.
Yeah,
I thought a little Brussels feelings.
Yes.
True.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's me.
Oh Wow.
So that's how I would bark at you.
Yeah.
I don't think we're over the line.
You think were crossed?
That was it.
I think we may have overstepped seriously.
We may have entered in a territory like officially in it for life.
Double the double leg back pull.
Yeah.
In their underwear.
I thought that was,
that may have,
may have put us into weird territory.
We should get the house phone.
It's a smart idea to know when can you run in there?
It's on the counter.
MMM.
Do you think that that may have may have affected us?
I feel like I can't unsee it.
That's the problem.
Like there's a reason you and I don't shit in front of each other.
Yeah.
Because I feel like that will,
but
that would put us into territory of like,
no,
going back.
We're brother and sister now.
Yeah,
I agree.
We don't do that.
We shouldn't,
shouldn't try.
I mean,
I don't know if this has been the line crossing.
Somebody sent in this evidence that you,
you are the FARC champ says I am.
Let's see though.
Let's see what it says.
MMM.
I Dunno.
I like those dog barks.
I love dogs.
Evidence that Tina
is the FARC champ.
Uh,
2013 episode one,
45,
13 gene with you and you have this horrible gas problem.
Uh,
you just let them rip all day.
And I'm like,
I love her.
What am I supposed to do?
And then you say you fire a lot more than me,
I think.
And I say no.
And you say,
who do you think so far it's more,
and I say you.
So it's kind of,
it's weird.
In this instance we're actually roll.
You're declaring declining that you are right.
I'm insisting that you are 2013.
Yeah.
Wow.
My things have changed since then.
Yeah.
So you,
you insisted that I was the fart champion.
This person says that.
Um,
in Fsos one,
two,
three 94,
yeah,
there is clear irrefutable evidence episodes one with that.
Tom Segura is the personality champ negative.
Yeah.
Begs on its countless hours.
He's more charming,
more likable overall has a better personality,
Dylan.
Yeah.
How many people I meet when I do my shows that come up to me and they're like,
you're the personality champ,
you're the best.
And then I just get tweets all day long.
It's like I can't even look at my Twitter feed,
you know,
telling me how much personality I have.
I don't think so.
I'm looking at you and you have this a horrible gas penis.
Yeah.
You just let them rap all day.
Oh yeah.
Me and I'm like,
I love her.
What am I supposed to do?
There you go.
You fart a lot more than me I think.
No.
Who Do you think for it's more,
yeah.
Well Shit you,
no way.
You let out a couple of monster ones.
Uh,
last night and or this morning?
This morning.
Yeah.
Well,
we ate a lot of pre Zuto and cheese last night for dinner.
Yeah.
You as you are insisting that I was right.
And you were saying that you weren't,
you were saying if you weren't,
you know what,
sometimes we're not always ready for greatness.
Yeah.
It's like you,
you become great.
That's what we're time.
You're not always ready to accept the title.
So that's what this is all about.
Podcast,
this podcast is about discovering oneself
and you're kind of at that point,
it's the farts of that steep bro,
bro is for yourself.
This is for farts.
Discovering.
Yeah.
It's uh,
it's pretty,
pretty wild that,
that we've gotten to this point where you're really finding out who's who and
what's what,
you know.
Yeah.
Bang.
My triple d slot wife.
Whoa.
Blue Band doesn't know about that.
You'll hear it.
That's how we kept saying that title over and over to ourselves,
over and over.
Stupid Bang.
My triple d slash wife bring my tripled who slept wife.
That's what it sounds like.
Yeah.
Bang.
My triple the slept wife.
Yeah.
Bang.
My triple D's slot life.
So any moment we should be joined by somebody,
it's going to be,
I think we should leave it as a surprise until he gets here just to be sure.
Yeah.
Yeah,
of course.
And it's not what you expect.
It's not a comic and entertainer,
but it is a field that is of great interest to both,
to both of us.
I'm more of an efficient auto.
I don't think so.
As usual.
You're ruining a great moment.
But um,
I think you guys will probably find this as interesting as I rolling.
Those are all signs of divorce.
What about him?
Contempt for your spouse?
That th that's the predictor of divorce and eye rolling is a huge predictor and
well,
a lot both in this family.
But what about it?
You constantly have contempt?
I don't constantly have contempt.
No,
I don't know.
Where is he?
She's here.
So
somebody tweeted a,
was it Sean Spicer to see if he had heard about the constraints and whether the
White House had comment on it.
What does this administration,
I think of the calm strike that's going on.
The what for and foreign come strike now.
I masturbated to everybody in my family.
It's so nuts.
She's so fucking crazy.
Um,
can't even imagine.
Hey,
so are fucking stupid dogs ran away last week.
I don't relive that.
That was terrible.
It was terrifying.
It was terrible.
So I was in here recording.
That's deep bro.
And I,
it was dinnertime.
So I opened that.
I usually keep them in here to record and then I let them into the house for
dinner time thinking that,
you know,
everybody would be there and I should have checked to make sure that the kitty
door was shut.
We had like a childproof fence for some reason.
I looked and I was like,
oh,
that's fine.
I didn't even like double check.
Um,
come back in here to record you.
Come in here.
Like,
is it,
are the dogs in here and the dogs in here?
I'm like,
no.
I'd say,
are the dogs in here?
I said,
is FIFA and FIFA Bach?
What was happening was I was upstairs,
I was on my computer.
The phone rings,
there's somebody outside and he goes,
is your dog bitsy?
Oh my God.
I'm like,
yeah.
He's like,
oh I have her outside.
So I run outside.
He's just standing.
This dude who I would not have guests would be the type of guy to do this.
And he did not look like,
oh,
kind of homeless?
No,
he just looked kind of,
um,
I don't know,
just kind of,
yeah,
he's kind of like a perv or something.
Yeah.
So I take bitsy in and then I'm in,
by the way on,
I go downstairs,
the front door's open,
just the front door to our house is open mindedness and then I grab her.
I'm terrified and I'm looking all around for,
I thought it features with you.
And then when he isn't like,
Oh shit.
And we just go outside and we start looking for them or looking for fee cause
bits is back here,
man.
We drove all over this neighborhood
yelling over the window,
asking anyone to see walking around.
Oh my God.
My favorite,
by the way,
is when we,
we fought,
there was one guy and I was like,
have you seen a dog,
a small blonde dog?
And he goes,
yeah,
no,
I haven't seen it.
You should find it before the sun goes down.
All those coyotes come out and I go,
thanks dude.
I hope.
Thank you.
I was like,
of course we're going to,
we're not gonna stop looking for him.
Like my,
I guess the sun's down.
We're going to stop looking for the dog that we've loved for the last six years,
asshole.
Of course we're going to do to,
anyway,
we finally did a phone call actually.
Uh,
we saw the woman walking away from our house,
but she left me a voicemail.
It didn't come through.
One of the neighbors found Fifo in her yard,
three houses down or four houses down and called the sac.
There we had,
we walked.
So that area too,
but he,
he was,
you know,
he's only what you inches off the ground.
It's scary though.
It was really scary the whole time.
I kept thinking,
I won't be able to sleep tonight if we don't find Fifo.
I would,
I would just be beside myself with grief.
Yeah.
It was first born son and how many hours in labor I spent without guy.
Anyways,
I bought a jeep dog gps for both of them.
They're both chipped,
but that you know that microchips shit doesn't work unless somebody turns them
into a vet or turns them into the shelter.
So that chip is not gps is not the same thing.
Yeah.
And um,
so I got them gps and I'm charging them now and then you put it on the color and
you can see it on your cell phone where they are and there's an electric fence
thing so that if they go out out of bounds it will notify you.
We got this email from a listener riding in hopes to shed light on this Dick
farting phenomenon so we can all know what's going on here.
I was glancing over your recent podcasts and I thought this could be a fantastic
learning experience for all involved.
Crones is a chronic inflammatory condition with that inflammation,
something called fistulas conform fistulas.
Basically a little tube that connects to hollow organs.
He's conformed between your bowel and blood vessels,
your skin and even yes,
your bladder.
And the last sort of this Sheila forms called an end Toro vascular fistula.
Aaron water waste products can travel from the bowel into the bladder.
This causes amazing Dick farting phenomena that we have grown to love today.
I'm actually graduating from medical school in a week.
Oh,
I know what I'm saying.
Know what I'm saying?
Put some respect on my leg,
on my name.
I love you.
Signed the Dick farting expert.
Hmm.
Really good.
All right,
here it was the dick part.
That is it.
Take for it.
Do the Dick farts.
Yeah.
Does it Dick farts smell like farts?
You know,
no one touched on that.
No one touched on that.
I mean it's air so it could stink.
Well he says it comes from the bowel.
Good.
So I'm assuming that those Dick farts smell like real farts.
Man.
This too was pissing that as far as we're coming out of his dick.
Okay.
Would you rather,
do you think this,
our guests is going to know what the topics are before he gets here?
We can have him chime in.
Would you rather tie a string around your balls and jump off?
Nope.
Nothing as batch or have dick farts for the rest of your life?
A hundred thousand day far today.
I'd rather just,
every time I take it out just parts of song.
Okay.
Would you rather dick farts for the rest of your life?
Yup.
Or one Drake from that guys nipples and you have to be like,
I'm super thirsty.
Oh,
he's like,
I saw stick and you're like,
I'm so thirsty side.
Um,
I'm so thirsty daddy.
That's what you have to say.
Daddy,
give me the milk.
I'm so thirsty.
God dammit.
I don't know where he is.
Oh,
he's here.
Say it in German.
You should have a desk.
I saw all the brands,
the
big map wash,
we dry,
I think.
I think I would take one of those over a lifetime.
A Dick farts.
Yeah.
Yeah,
because Dick farts.
There'll be a really bad though to do this.
This be a really bad,
he doesn't have milk in his breasts.
First of all,
fucking vomit going on now.
Do men have milk ducts?
I think they do.
I think you could.
Can you a lactaid.
Oh Man.
I wonder,
can men listen?
Army man,
I don't know.
Our nipples are different.
So I don't,
I don't know.
Do you have milk?
Oh,
it's so gross.
It's so disgusting.
A medical Dr. Guy.
Can Men lactate?
Can men produce milk?
I know that they must have similar equipment.
Look in Utero.
That's why men have stop it with the fucking bar.
You know,
I don't like it.
Don't laugh.
Blue Band.
It's legitimate phobia.
I have,
I fucking hate it dude.
It's not,
yeah,
it's real.
It's a fucking real mental problem.
I have,
I see a fucking shrink for it.
Please.
Dammit.
I love doing that to you.
I know you do.
That's what happens on this
content.
So let's,
uh,
let's break and hopefully in a few moments,
few minutes we'll return with a guest that we're very excited about.
Show me how those Dick farts smell.
Okay.
We'll be right back.
All right,
so we're back.
And uh,
you don't know that before you got here,
this show had a lot of different topics.
Most of them were between our NC 17 and triple x and now it's a total change of
pace and we're very happy.
Happy to welcome,
by the way.
You are our first guest and not exaggerating here in a couple of years.
Oh my gosh.
We used to have guests all the time.
We have the foremost water,
someone Yay in the United States and actually in the world.
Even the both know sometimes scary for me to get closer to that.
Sorry.
Sometimes it's scary for me that I'm that famous already.
And that you are,
it's Martin Reese,
correct?
Yeah.
Actually it's like Porsche.
Porsche.
Does it annoy you?
How many people say Porsche wrong?
They should say Porsche,
right?
Um,
I'm brave.
Branch on you deal with it.
We live with the snow that I want to give people the background to this.
So what happened was I actually saw a different,
one of your competitors,
a water,
someone a on CNN.
There was a like a piece on him and he was in Asia.
Shanghai.
I will meet him in June.
Who is this guy?
Do you like him?
Do you hate him?
No,
we don't know.
I love everybody who drinks water.
Well,
so
I saw,
I saw I'm wearing a water champ hat.
For those of you listening.
I saw this piece and I thought,
oh,
this is fascinating.
But then I saw it in Shanghai and I go,
ah,
well I guess that'll never happen.
Then I'm on Instagram and I see this 62nd piece on you and I'm watching it.
I'm like,
oh cool.
Another water,
someone gay.
And then I see in la immediately I go to your website,
it's Martin Hyphen Reese,
[inaudible] dot com and I email about uh,
a class you do like private or group clap and you hit me back and you said like,
you're the water champ.
How about we get together factually accurate Martin,
that is actually you.
You have no idea.
He did not write back to you and say you're the water.
Just exactly what he said.
I'll show you the email.
No.
Now here's the thing,
just to get people,
like most people know the word,
some Yay.
And that that always is,
you know,
high end restaurant.
They have a summer,
Yay to tell you about wines and their origin and how do you come about becoming
a water somewhere yet?
So I have to say it started when I was a child,
so on vacation time with my parents,
I tasted the different tech borders all around the world when it wasn't vacation
and my parents always thought like,
Hey,
what's wrong with our sandwich?
It's like wanting to the tap when we end the new city or something.
It's like,
what's what's up with him?
And for me it was like,
hey dude,
what do you think about the taste of the top board?
And she's like,
what?
It's like,
what's up?
It's like no it,
and for me as a child,
it was fascinating that everybody said,
yeah,
it's tap water.
And I felt like,
but there are so many different roles as in tap water even.
Isn't it funny though,
right,
that this is something that basically we all,
I feel like everybody senses that,
but you acted on it.
In other words,
we all tried to tap waters as a kid especially,
and you're like that,
but I feel like you're the one who was talking about it.
I think the thing is with Kitson,
I see it right now in my water tasting classes as well.
Kids love that because kits tastes pets,
uh,
still like super fresh.
They are not like completely ruined already because they didn't have too much
spicy food or drink or alcohol or something like this.
So they can really detect a lot of stuff in water.
So you say that that can actually dial your palate is having spicy foods
drinking,
recording,
you get exposed to so many different like taste profiles and water,
very settling taste.
We're not talking about wine,
we're like different colors,
different grapes,
different vintages,
different barrel fermentations by water.
It's hopefully all it comes from nature and it's all about the middle content.
So as a child I realized what has taste and then in 2005,
I worked in a restaurant in Germany at the restaurant,
first floor and a customer came up to me and said,
hey Madden,
you have so many different wines but you're just serving one brand of wardrobe
and I don't like this particular brand.
Do you have something else for me?
And I was like looking at him and I thought I'd like to know what he's up seated
right in the restaurant business,
all about options.
You have different liquors,
you have different beers on tap,
you have different wines on the menu.
But when it comes to water the summer,
we'll ask you sparkling flood or tip,
what are your rights and sparkling or bottled never tap.
So I thought scas change it and I wanted to give options to my guests.
I created a water menu in 2005 so a lot of people always saying like,
oh,
only in la they're so gorgeous.
So many.
Yeah.
Actually I'm doing this since over 10 years now.
Cool man.
And like all our water competitions aside,
we are big fans of Wa like water in general.
Like we,
we all,
it started because,
you know,
we,
we were both drinking water and,
and had this banter back and forth about like who drinks more.
But the truth is I do
love trying out different waters and I feel like,
I dunno,
I can't speak for the rest of the world,
but it's always a thing here in the United States that that argument about,
you know,
if you go and you and you buy this water,
it's just,
that's just uh,
someone took their,
their,
their hose and the back and filled this thing up.
Right.
And you can be how many comments I had on my social media pages of all this.
Come on Matson,
you'll just have a big hole somewhere in your back yard.
You're putting all of the different,
different voltage shapes and then you putting all this water in the sink.
Yeah.
Right.
But there really is serious differences.
I mean,
I think the inexperienced person knows that,
that,
you know,
different waters taste differently,
but it's easiest form to explain the difference really comes down to mineral
content,
right?
Correct.
So it can measure by tds,
total dissolved solids.
Okay.
One question now,
because I grew up in La and never drink the tap water.
I mean,
I'm convinced it's just poison running through.
And so it's also like what do you buy as e what does the average person by to
have in their home?
So that's another thing I would ask you,
cause we did Sparklets for awhile and that was fine.
But now we have a water filtration system built into our house and that's,
I don't know,
is it better?
So that too,
I would like to know from you.
So the thing is when it comes to vogue,
and I think the biggest important thing is that people need to understand where
their water's coming from.
And it is kind of sad that's here in America.
A lot of purified water companies,
I like the new hip thing and everybody thinks water should be pure.
I'm always seeing water should not be pure because when it's completely pure,
you don't want to drink it because your body needs minerals all the time.
Like magnesium,
calcium,
potassium,
silica or this different minerals.
What your body cannot produce by himself.
So your body needs constantly minerals.
That's the reason you are hungry.
That's the reason you're thirsty because your body wants minerals.
So to have a water kind of like say a attempt water filled out everything out of
there and then it's like super pure water.
Pure,
um,
with zero tds is actually extremely harmful for your buddy because you have no
minerals,
no middle,
it's soul,
your body drinks that mother nature doesn't know the concept of completely pure
water.
It doesn't exist in mother nature.
Right?
So you're drinking that water,
the body things like what the hell is that?
It's like,
I don't even know what this element is,
not what I just drunk.
Um,
I need to put minerals in it to process it,
to get rid of it.
So you're actually dehydrating by drink distilled water.
Wow.
Can you and can I tell you,
because when I did drink tap water,
like on the emergency days when we'd run out of lit,
I swear I would feel thirsty or after drinking tap water.
It never,
but the fun thing,
and I don't want to radio your mind,
no.
Um,
la tap water is actually way more minerals than all the purified water
companies.
So when you want to stick to a mineral content drink la Tub.
So I think even when I would choose a bottle of like a purified water and you
can see it on the label,
purified water here,
what I brought,
it's all Springwater's and that's the only thing I always promote.
You have waters I've never heard of.
This is what I'm so excited about.
I mean there's definitely,
I would say amongst,
I will call us the,
the regular civilians who are not in your,
uh,
your league of knowledge.
Everybody kind of kind of thinks that Fiji is the,
you know,
between,
uh,
Evian and feed you.
They're like,
those are,
that's high end water.
Usually you pay more for those two in a convenience store,
you know,
seven,
11.
And I,
I've,
in my own Palette,
I do feel like I taste Fiji as different than other bottled waters that are
around.
In other words,
the,
the whatever yellow spring,
I forget,
there's a Florida springs one and there's a Disani,
which I don't like to sing at all.
It's purified.
I don't like to watch them shipping everything out of there.
They're adding back some very small amount of minerals that amount and then
sending it flight price.
In my opinion,
the biggest scam on planet earth is Disani.
Yes,
in general for flood water companies.
That's for me something what I drives me crazy and I came to the states in 2011
and I wanted to create a water menu right away and it was so hard to find real
Springwater's in America.
Of course mostly here the water's up per flight Walters and let's face it,
hey,
they all bind big companies and the big companies wants to make money and it's
quick.
I corner Denon,
Nestle and Pepsi are the four biggest water producers in the world and they'll
all want to make money with us so therefore it's easier to use.
Just tap water filtering everything older,
they are adding back some minerals just for taste profile.
That's like the water's kind of okay and sending it for a price.
Therefore I'm sticking always to springwater and this is what I always recommend
when you're going to a grocery store.
Just check the labels.
Look for spring glacier or natural source mineral water and do not buy purified
water.
Purified water.
Essentially doing harm to yourself with,
I don't want to say hum,
but you will harm yourself.
Definitely buy distilled water when you're buying the gallons of distilled water
is created for like auto batteries.
It's for your irn.
It's not for consumption and in Germany they're big labels on this bottles what
you can buy a swan.
The grocery store do not drink.
Not for human consumption.
Really?
Why?
In America they are like,
yeah,
whatever.
They stood water.
That's so cool.
It's so pure.
So marketing plays a big role in private water companies is still people at the
gym where they get enough distilled water choking that down and then they're
wondering why they're suddenly like feeling not really good and why they're
always have headaches.
Yeah,
dehydrating the whole time.
That's what I drank during that water cut when I was doing a a weight loss
contest.
You're trying to cut water.
The last few days,
the fighters,
they told me that the way you do it is you drink distilled water to flush your
toilet flushing every exactly,
but over a longer time.
Oh yeah.
Now it's World Health Organization.
Even saying it can be very harmful for your you on,
what about avi-on?
Is that a good one?
I feel like it tastes to me it just tastes so pure and good.
So that one's a good one.
It's so funny.
If y'all had a,
has a love and hate relationship to guests.
It's so funny.
Some people saying I love evo.
Some people saying I hate Avr and that is the reason why I have a water menu at
the restaurant is so wow.
It's actually so simple when you think about it.
That's actually a very simple concept.
Can we tell the people what restaurant Patina restaurant at the Walt Disney
concert hall and that is a downtown Los Angeles.
Los Angeles.
I went to interview for a job.
Are there,
uh,
like 10 plus years ago?
Yeah.
My sister used to work for the Patina group that is funding.
So she set me up and I went in for an interview and,
uh,
I didn't get the job.
Was it a big job fair or what was it?
No,
no,
like she like set me up for,
I forget if it was hosting or,
um,
I dunno,
something like that.
I had zero restaurant experience,
but I went in and like I had on a suit and I,
it's so funny,
kind of try to say I love people who have zero experience because then I can
actually formed them.
That's way better for me.
I like people who are saying doing what Martin,
I never walked in the restroom before,
but I really are eager to do it and I'm a hot chicken guy.
That's for me thousand times better than people who were coming to me and say
like,
yeah,
I'm blocked and all this fancy places and I know way more than you.
That's true.
Yeah.
Right.
Oh,
this will be trouble already.
That's true.
Laurie steakhouse downtown.
But then I failed the drug test cause I smoked pot the night before.
You did the night before she started to relax for the entire,
yeah,
no,
I'm excited to jump in and try some waters.
Another thing we did,
because we were talking about this even before you got here,
I definitely want to do this.
I have a glass of our filtered system water.
Can I give you
put too much in it but I wouldn't just want to see what really interesting me.
So the first,
the first thing,
what I'm doing,
and this is already when people saying like what the Hell is Martin doing?
Why is he looking at a glass of water?
And I can already see something like if there's any middle content,
if I can see something on the tds level,
it's,
but they asked like it looks pretty pure to me in this way.
There are some of the residuals right here,
but that's might be the class of Polish and Rick.
So let's see.
Smiling,
there's no chlorine smell.
So that's only a good sign because your filtration systems obviously in a good
shape because sometimes the problem with flotation system as well that people
buying themselves a filtration system,
but you never think about maybe changing the filters on top of it because it has
a light that tells me where,
okay good.
When it turns yellow,
why buy the filter in a lot of pictures of their filtration system in their
fridges and they think like,
oh,
I got my grade water from the fridge.
And they are like putting this for many,
many years out of the fridge.
Never changed their filter.
What that means.
The Philadelphia bucked up one at one point with all this stuff,
what you don't want to have in your water and then it's actually harmful right
by the shoulders.
So filled up that it actually poisons the water.
What's going on there.
So please guys,
when you're the filtration system at home to change your filters all the time.
Sure.
Cheers.
Going to see what we're doing here.
So the middle content is very low from convey this right away.
Fuck.
Um,
it's a,
it's a pleasant water I think to drink.
That's definitely the mineral content is low filtration system normal.
This is totally normal.
I think of if I have a filtration system at home as well,
so don't worry about it.
I'm using it like for showering,
for cooking,
for all this kinds of stuff.
But when it comes to adjust regular drinking on their daily basis,
I'm sticking to bottled water because I want to have,
I want to have for little the right yet swat and all of these that we're looking
at here,
these all are different to the pallet.
Every single one of these.
Yeah,
definitely.
And price wise,
like when we,
when we talk about,
um,
for instance,
wines,
right?
Wines,
people who don't buy wines a lot,
they just go,
that's really expensive.
Um,
it must be amazing and don't realize that a lot of the times what the price is
indicative of is the exclusivity of it.
In other words,
they make less of these,
therefore the price is much higher expected.
The same with volume.
So there's the more expensive ones are just less mass produced.
For example,
I brought several waters.
CN is skilled,
it's a good example for it.
Wine is skilled is way more expensive than maybe an if y'all,
what you can buy at the grocery store.
Great hoarders,
but it's skilled.
It produces a million bottles per year.
This is in the industry like nothing pillar.
Vena would laugh about that number.
I see.
They are pumping out a million bottles per week.
So for them it's just like,
what do they want it skilled.
It's a very small spring has been discovered by a retirement couple in 2003
record.
They wanted to build a small little vacation house in Denmark in a national
reservoir.
And the Danish government was saying,
yeah,
you can build your house.
They are,
but you cannot bring a water pipeline through our natural reservoir.
And they thought like,
okay,
back to the nature,
it's nice,
but like no water's a little bit too much for us in nature.
So they found a spring,
send it over to our lab and the lab said like,
well wait a minute,
what's up with the order?
There's something very unique about it.
And they thought like,
Oh shit.
Like maybe it's not good,
the water or something.
When the levers doing this whole fuss about it,
they found the most unique water ever been found in this bring is super,
super small and therefore I been to the spring for six years ago.
It's like the spring house is the size of this building here.
It's like super small and when you're thinking about this and you like,
you see seen this to people,
they're smiling at you and like,
yeah,
we found this cool watch and we've,
we wanted to share it with the world and now they're battling is skilled or
mean.
She actually ice spring and the Danish language,
I love this kind of stories and every water has a little story to it and I think
this is really cool to discover and then,
yeah,
sure you're paying like,
I think you can find it at Erewhon now for three or $4.
It's a little bit more expensive,
but it's cool.
It's a nice story to it.
And this is nothing what I would drink on a daily basis because hey,
I,
I need to watch my money as well,
like everybody else.
So therefore I have big gallons of arrowheads at my place.
That spot while I'm drinking on a daily basis or what?
I'm going to a grocery store like Fiji,
that's my go to a or arrowhead is what you're saying.
Spring when I'm going to a what?
A grocery store because I love Fiji water.
It has a very high silica content at city comics.
What?
Extremely smooth.
That's what it is.
C and I,
can I tell you something before this is confirmed,
I thought I was crazy when I would think about the idea that Fiji tasted smooth
to me cause that's it.
That would be the first word that I would describe it as.
And I,
you know,
I didn't,
I didn't know any of this,
but it does to the Palette and your mind,
you're like this,
why does this taste like silky smooth?
This is the reason because this water has one of the highest silica content,
whatever been found in silicon.
Silicon.
Okay.
And that's a mineral.
It's a natural occurring mineral.
I love it.
How do you say that in German again?
Cheers.
Post,
post,
post.
How do I do that thing you're doing?
So when,
uh,
when I compare it to your filtration system,
they are both on room temperature,
but it fuels that features more refreshing.
Yes.
It has more mental of content.
100%.
So the mineral content gives you that,
that feeling.
Do you think about a soup without salt?
Right,
right.
You'll,
this is like very bland and you want a little salt to kickoff the soup.
It's the same with water.
No water with no mineral content block.
It's like boom in your palate flat and it makes you thirstier like you just
drank our house swell.
That was our house smelled
like apologizing.
Shitty water.
If you have to.
Totally different.
So you can measure,
you can measure the middle content by tds,
total dissolved solids.
And this water has a tds log of 222,
uh,
Elliot tap.
A lot of people will surprise slope between 200 and 400 tds,
purified water companies,
maximum of 40 tedious.
Oh,
did you see like,
oops,
like one of the waters,
uh,
people think they're getting very smart when they're drinking that water.
Um,
by Jennifer Anderson.
uh,
it's actually owned by corporate corner.
People don't know that a lot of people drink that water but don't know it.
But they're putting on their labels,
edit electrolytes and everybody's like,
yeah,
cool.
Electrolytes,
electrolytes.
Yeah.
Elliot Test Pass has 10 times more electrolytes than wait.
Smart.
The smartwater smartwater.
Yup.
That's that nonsense.
You buy at trader Joe's.
So they add electrolytes,
smartwater,
heading electrolytes,
but in very small amounts.
And that is always the cool thing that people don't understand.
Like,
oh,
they edit electrolytes,
but they don't tell you how many.
So fishy water has way more electrolytes than smart board.
Wow.
No,
anymore.
I mean,
Europe,
there's lots of natural springs everywhere.
I feel like that's a very euro thing.
Like I know my family,
we go to a place called Havius,
which is like on the border,
whereas in,
is it Austria?
And Hungary,
some natural spring,
like Europeans love their natural,
we swim in it,
you drink it,
you bay that to very euro.
I think this has something to do with the culture in Europe because like yeah,
just said bathing in it.
So spy areas are very famous all over Europe.
So people went to the spidery,
a speck in the days.
This one still doing it for health benefits and they want to make sure,
yes,
right,
but they want to treat themselves on water in bad thing or even by drinking.
Therefore they understood the concept that water is extremely important,
that it's actually the invention of buttered Raja.
The first invention was the first bottled water came from spy areas as
medication because medication was not prevented.
People went to the spider is to get healthy again or like to have a health
product because the waters has a lot of minerals in it like Hudson,
magnesium,
all this kind of minutes.
While it's extremely good for you.
When the people who were too sick to it,
this pub,
people started to bottle,
they've waters and sent them over to the sick people.
So medication was invented.
Bottled water.
Wasn't that amazing?
No.
These days a lot of bottled water.
It's more like hydration,
just hydration.
But back in the days,
the history of bout buttered water's actually medication.
Do you have a number that you try to hit a as far as consumption per day?
Do you try to,
um,
it really depends what you're doing.
It depends what kind of exercise you're doing.
So for me as a restaurant person who walks around the restaurant all the time,
I did the yesterday 25,000 steps on Mother's Day obviously.
What does that equal pay day or something like this?
Easy.
We were slightly busy.
Um,
I've drink a lot of water,
but I'm trying and this is the key as well.
Drink the whole time and not just think or I drink a gallon in the morning and
drink a gallon and you can,
that's pretty much it.
That doesn't work.
You need to hydrate yourself over.
That is the key about water and drinking water.
Do not think you can hydrate yourself.
Thinks I know the water shimmers in the room as well and he was able to gallons
in six hours.
Yeah,
it's pretty crazy.
And I wanted to tell you a little story.
What has kind of like a sad story,
what happens here in California,
somebody had a big game and a radio show how much water you can drink at one
hour and that didn't work out well,
now someone died,
right?
Yep.
So this person,
we're able to drink I think 12 bottles of of leaders.
So 12 liters of water and one hour and the hole was,
the whole game was like,
hey,
try to drink so much water in this hour.
And then they don't pee when we,
we need 10 days,
three hours later she died because you can something too much water until your
buddy,
your sales were like literally like over swept of it blowing up and she
completely drowned from inside and let us very sad.
So please guys,
I know,
don't overthink it.
Don't drink too much water as well.
That's really possibilities to obviously not drink enough.
Water is definitely my the other way.
No,
I actually went to a urologist a few years ago and I asked him,
uh,
because I was like,
how much water should I be drinking?
And he goes,
however much you feel if you feel thirsty,
drink off.
Plus what you're saying,
it was like,
oh I thought there was this rule that I have to have eight ounces every two
hours or whatever bullshit.
Cause that was a thing I feel like
a few years ago tried to tell you to drink so much.
Have to have those managers per day or something like this tense when you're
sitting in an office and its stock,
you don't need so much water than people obviously worked on the street.
Right.
So it really depends what you're doing.
People who are exercise and extremely having like jobs like somewhere where they
like move the whole time.
It's way more water.
Yeah.
Then people were sitting the whole day.
Yes,
totally normal.
But the key is drink water.
That's the most important thing.
Do not start to drink sodas.
Even when you think ace,
what does this mean?
90% of water.
But let's face it,
all the calories here than when I read it.
Yeah.
Question.
Now that brings us to our soda question.
Loquat Lacroix liquid.
I don't know how you pronounce,
uh,
what's the,
is that water or is that time?
My husband seems to think it's more water than soda.
Uh,
there are some waters like vitamin water waters for the even claiming themselves
that this is water.
Let's face it.
The vitamin waters,
the soda,
sugar and sugar.
Wanting to know what about the zero calorie zero xe via the Cli?
Like are those water,
I mean they're obviously there's,
there's,
there's a carbonation in it.
Would you like me to get one,
couple nation to it?
Yeah.
So this didn't happen.
This is totally anonymous.
Some bottled water companies are doing this.
For example,
Mon Valley Springs are very good water from America.
I love that water.
It's a stills.
It's still spring.
And the adding combination too at the same actually was some Pellegrino.
Simply Rubino is a Stillwater.
Oh,
it is adding them and adding the combination to it.
You will not find a San Pellegrino as a still version on this planet because
they're marketing themselves as a sparkling water adding actually see two to
wow.
Wow.
So that actually is your drinking water.
I mean that's what our water,
sure it's motto.
Yeah.
But I talk a little bit about it skilled and I think we shouldn't so excited.
And I said the cool story and maybe you couldn't hear it right when I'm opening
the bottle.
It's still,
yeah,
it's still water,
but still something happened right then.
Now I may not use the same glasses I drank my Fijian cause that would be
contaminating with water flavors.
Is that right?
Well the minerals,
right?
They could be mineral,
mineral residue,
mix it,
but suddenly you weren't getting something is happening.
And when you're looking at this class now versus the future glass before,
by the way,
this conversation,
I'd be like,
throw this shit out.
This is bad.
Like that's already something going on here.
Yeah.
And there's bubbles.
They love any,
but it's still a wardrobe.
So let's see what's happening.
What?
I'm shaking this bottle because it's a still water and I'm not just the only
water.
So many in America.
I'm actually the David Copperfield of waters.
I can do some magic with us as well.
Okay.
So I can turn this into a million.
Ah,
let's see.
Looks clear to you.
Yeah.
Everything is good.
Here we go.
Right?
Wow.
That's a mineral bath dude.
No,
I feel like I have seen.
That's crazy.
This is insane.
And then you see like really slowly right here.
Yeah,
it disappears.
Wow.
It's actually not the minerals.
What is it?
It's not Kevin of minutes.
What do you think guys come about?
Can it be,
nope.
Nope.
Air Efficiency.
Carcinogen.
Oxygen,
oxygen,
oxygen.
This Walter has a high oxygen content than all waters ever been found in
Denmark.
That's the reason the lab was so off was this and said like what the Hell is
going on here?
And they found out is skilled at what I said.
I spring in the Danish language,
they found out that this is a very,
very old springwater around 7,500 year old,
but we have in this class.
Right.
And the cool thing about this is that cold water holds more oxygen than warm
water does.
That's the reason.
Sometimes New York in the winter time when you open the tap water,
it's sometimes cloudy as well.
And then that's what I'm thinking.
I've stayed in hotels where that type of thing happens and I go,
I'm not drinking this shit.
But that's my first thought types are exposed to extremely cold temperatures
outside.
Yeah.
And that's the reason this water turns into this very cloudy,
cloudy Brian,
uh,
tastewise any heads up on what we're going to experience as opposed to the,
I always say as Tom Mcgee would be a bad,
somebody,
one of you tell her you're right away,
right.
What you think,
what the taste would be.
Okay.
So I think you should discover if you'll see something at,
and be honest,
maybe you see like some people have a hard time to divine feature versus skilled
it.
So she has goes cheers.
Oh my God.
No,
totally different.
Totally different.
Especially the after taste.
The aftertaste is very distinct.
Okay.
It smells like Europe is reminds me of of going to like a thermal bath or
mineral bad,
whatever it with my parents that Fiji still has a much more like when I do it
right after,
especially a much,
the smoothness is still stands out as very different.
It does have like a 10 year or whatever.
I don't know how to describe it after taste.
Right.
You're like,
oh that's a,
there's a minerals.
Yes,
definitely.
Yeah.
There's sodium contents we hired.
The tds is no 400 so it's almost a double of the mineral content or Fiji and
interesting.
What I think of especially about the aftertaste a of skilled,
it has like the slightly earthy notes to it.
Like think about a mushroom or something like this that's familiar.
There's things just taste a skilled that I've been in China last year and a big
water tastes and competition and I had to taste 80 different Walters blind.
Why?
Say they gave me just the glasses like this and then drink it and then I hit to
cavort like what I think about the water.
They gave me a skilled and I will,
I knew right away it's a skill you did.
Yup.
I had 100% right away.
I gave her 100% or a hundred points to it as skilled as well because for me it's
one of the best waters I ever tasted a.
For me it's just like there's so much characteristic in it.
I love the idea about the oxygen level as well that this water turns into like
the slightly milkiness to it.
It's just mind blowing water.
That's a me and then to be clear,
did you say this is,
you can get it three or $4 Arrow
get that.
That is,
it's pretty cool.
I mean that's a really cool thing.
I think it's a very accessible price point for an experience.
In other words,
somebody wants to try this like it's three or four bucks.
We can definitely do it.
We're not talking about like the headwaters for over $75 already.
What the most expensive one I ever drank his hundred thousand dollars
I did this with Diplo and two Chainz
with Diplo and to change.
Yes,
you can see it for Gq magazine,
the most expensive shit or his digged it.
Did that come out of,
why is it a hundred grand?
You can see it almost 8 million clicks or any of the words.
It's hilarious.
Where's it from?
Yeah.
Then actually it's from California dog right away at all.
It's Beverly hills nine or each tool with 50 white diamonds on the cab is so
right.
The water itself is very good as well.
Um,
but obviously this is more like a funny,
cool idea.
Just create a very crazy priced diamond water.
Um,
I don't know if you watch that reality show that,
can you,
can you infuse,
does it matter if you
see a boat when you believe in something?
That's a very diplomatic answer from Marta and I'm like,
it's all about minerals for me.
It's for me in the middle.
It's a scientific fact that water has middles dissolved.
Of course,
it comes from the disc rounds,
borders.
Tara.
Fascinating.
Um,
what's up with Hilden?
What's,
that's our next one.
Our next one.
So we need to save some glasses so I will see a little less guilty.
Okay.
How do you say water champion in German?
Durvasa champion.
Diversity champion.
Yeah.
So Hilton is a sparkling water
and this is the official reward of the Queen.
She drinks this water all the time.
This is the queens,
the queens water.
And is it,
where's it from?
Uh,
from England.
A spot.
And you have to be a little careful because when you're drinking too much Hilton
water,
your arms have any,
we'll do like this or like this.
Yeah,
I do see a distinctive snow bubbles.
Bubbles.
And they're bigger.
They're,
they look like they're big bubbles.
Bubbles.
And again,
like in the beginning,
everybody watched me looking at the glass and now you guys doing this as well.
But of course you can already see,
okay.
Obviously we're talking here about a carbonated water and the collage,
what I would say to it right now,
it's pretty big,
interesting fact about this.
Just that the carbonation levels actually very low,
but it's just like some big bubbles in Zoloft in that water.
But it's not like this progressive like maybe a girl or from Germany or some
pig.
We know what has like tons of bottles.
I hate hands bubbles.
This is like gently spark.
Well she's the queen man.
She is.
Cheers,
pops,
pops.
I love it.
See and to me this is so European to American bottled waters.
I mean the sparkling water is never taste the subtle and the court telling your
right away as well.
What's actually in here.
And this is kind of sad that low slowly the purified water companies,
especially again,
they don't tell you at all what they're adding.
He had says right away,
magnesium content,
1.7 cards,
Yom 97 sodium 7.7 chloride 60 and fluoride a to 12 degrees,
the 0.02.
So it's super low.
What it should be in water because fluoride is not really something what you'll
want to want to drink the whole time and totally self taught a 312 so they're
adding this right away.
Honestly,
I think the biggest eye opener,
at least for me and I think I imagine for people listening is the idea that
reading that there's things in your water doesn't an equal,
uh,
automatically or in any way necessarily bad thing.
Cause I think every one of us probably who doesn't know,
oh that's bad.
I want minerals.
Pure concept is crazy silliness.
I would drink a lot more sparkling water if it weren't for the saltiness,
the sodium content.
I find that a lot of them are very salty.
You can feel it will be tough for you guys cause those are salty waters.
So would you consider it,
so is this a nice option if you're going to go for a sparkling water,
would you say that I love Philip.
The sodium content is very low.
It's not that salty.
The bubbles are very tiny.
It's not like this progressive in your palate that spoken easily.
Chuffed on this bottle and it's not like that.
You're like feeling like blowing up right away.
Now can I ask you how you have a water menu that you offer?
I feel like we go to a lot of Nice restaurants and travel a lot and still,
even in high end restaurants,
I get the question tab still or sparkling.
In other words,
there's no other,
is the options thing going to be developing more you think in restaurants?
I really hope so.
And I think the first concept is that people need to understand that they should
drink more water.
And finally in America,
a bottled waters,
the most consumed product now and sorta not anymore.
So this is already amazing since 2016 bottled water is the number one consumer
product.
And I love this,
I love to hear this.
Or obviously the Americans understand that sorta this might be not the best
choice to drink antitrust yourself on it.
Yeah,
no.
The next step is to understand that water is not just water.
Yeah.
And that they are big water tea or at differences.
And again,
some water,
they're coming from an ethical source that's actually nothing other than UTEP
border.
So just drink tip and save the money or other water's coming from the different
regions of the world and therefore their tastes differently.
Wow.
That's the whole coastline.
My mind.
This is blowing my mind.
Um,
so let's see.
This is,
is this a sparkling water or your best?
That's a sprocket.
Walter Vichy Catalan fishy colon is like the arrowhead have spent,
this is the number one consumed sparkling water and Spain.
Uh,
I've been on Conan O'brien as well for 12 years ago.
I did a water tasting with him and he spit out that water.
Really?
Yup.
It was like,
what the hell is going on here?
It's like he didn't believe me that this is coming from nature.
Wow.
Did he really?
Yeah.
He thought I put like an aspirin.
And this is,
um,
this is,
uh,
produced in Spain are the words that hundred miles up north from Barcelona is
the spring located.
It's a spring.
It's a spring of water,
a hundred percent spring water.
Natural Queen comes,
raises up 140 degrees Fahrenheit.
What's a super hot spring?
What writes up the water?
So we had a very cold spring is skilled versus nowhere.
Very hot spring.
Vichy Catalan up.
You'll see the buttons already have way more progressive than in the Hilton or
they look at Hilton right now.
There are almost no bubbles anymore.
It feels like there's really something going on.
Okay,
awesome.
Oh my goodness dude.
That is like an explosion of saltiness.
Oh yeah.
It's a very bitter at the end.
Very salty.
I also,
by the way,
what quality is it?
Cause now I can,
I can,
it takes me back now that I've had Stillwater in traveling that has some of that
taste.
Is that,
is that the sodium?
The sodium.
So yes,
the soldier was the first thing you can,
you can get it over with.
That's really strong.
And this is right away.
We talking about over a thousand milligrams of salt.
Salty.
It's crazy.
The tds level is mind blowing.
3050.
Why?
It has more electrolytes than a Gatorade.
It's going on with the Spaniards.
Sam,
where are they doing?
What's wrong with it?
The reason they're,
so I'd rate it.
Maybe.
Maybe it's facing the Spanish people.
That's the reason they love this water.
It's super hot outside in Spain,
like here in La.
Um,
so you're spending all the time and when you're sweating you're losing minerals.
Yeah,
that's pretty much because that's the reason you were spared a salty.
So when you compare a fissure colon and drink this all the time,
you're getting all your middle Spec.
Wow.
The thing is what you cannot do,
a lot of people always seem like,
oh just bottled water and then you'll be fine.
That doesn't work as well because we all know around two days it takes her to
dehydrate and then you will die after two or three days and after two or three
weeks you will die because you didn't hit any food.
So your body,
the most mineral,
it's what your body needs comes from food.
But growth and food,
there's way more minutes actually then bottled water,
right?
But bottled waters,
a core theme because the middle told where you dissolved s water.
So it's very easy to access is for your buddy.
The middles.
Cause you don't need really to process it.
And let's think about alkaline water.
Everybody talks about color.
So important align.
That's a very,
it's also very trendy right now.
Very Trendy head needs to be balanced.
And some people are saying,
I can land.
You can balance out your body with this because your body is acidic because
you're eating so much acidic food.
And with an iCloud you can balance Rgo your body Ph and then your healthy
completely bullshit goes and not to live in that literary crap because when you
drink water,
what we just did,
it goes into your stomach.
So your stomach is up with fluid and the seventh note is extremely acidic.
So water will turn like this acidic.
So that whole idea about,
or you can balance out something with a Ph level is completely nonsense.
Highly upset.
Your stomach is,
has a break down their food.
Therefore,
this whole idea about I can land water,
do not believe in this whole claims.
By the way,
I can't believe how we haven't put this together yet with Martin here.
Uh,
do you know this clip?
The
Dry?
It's
a German man.
He also is there,
but he's providing the seas first in a different way.
I wanted you to know what kind of show you were on it.
You're like,
we've misled on playboy radio.
Okay.
And when the bunnies had this water in their mouth,
they're also like,
oh,
it tastes like,
Oh really?
Like
10 times worse than that.
100 times we're going.
Then we have
crazy one that blew my mind.
No,
this start of a little taste.
Wow.
Let's go move on.
So your Palette,
I mean you have to keep it so sensitive.
How do you maintain your palate flavor?
You're,
I don't drink any hard liquor.
No hard liquor.
Don't want chemo cocktails.
I cannot stand cocktail.
There's too much sugar.
That's the reason I don't like cocktails.
I don't drink hard liquor at all.
I love wine and sparkling wines.
This is like what I'm drinking when I've like to boost up.
How about coffee?
No coffee.
What is that for your palate for?
Just kind of like the taste.
It's too bitter for me.
Maybe every coffee I tasted so far is always just bitter.
And I think my palette,
it's just like involved over so many years not to drink so much water that my
palace extremely sensitive.
I want to ask someone,
will you grab from the fridge a z via and Alliqua?
Yep.
Thank you.
The cool thing as well is about drinking water.
And I hit this with the Sagat.
I had a video,
it's on youtube as well with a girl from Zagat and weird tasting,
different waters and she never drank so much water and you'll seeing the end of
the video,
she's,
she feels like wasted now.
She didn't have any Oklahoma,
but she fits like she started to a tickling and like,
and it's like I got drunk and she's like,
I don't know,
but I feel like a little tipsy tipsy.
And I think it was like she might be as a person who doesn't drink so much water
all the time.
Then I exposed her to so much water and too extremely high mineral content.
Water that's her body was like really reacting to it.
It feels like she was like on a stats.
Bizarre.
Crazy.
But as you can see it on youtube,
it's kind of,
it's kind of funny.
He really says like in the camera thing,
I feel really drunk.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And water has an impact on your buddies?
Absolutely is.
It's crazy and it's cool.
Um,
are we brought these in because this Christina made a good point.
Like what,
what is going on with these?
Um,
I know that La Quilla exist.
I have to say I never had it before.
It's so funny.
I know their big sodium free.
Yeah.
And the Z Veo one there,
the one that he just put on that table,
um,
it has,
it's the contents on it as well.
The funny thing is here they don't tell you where this water is extra coming
from.
That's always a red flag always for me.
Okay.
Cause ingredients cabin in the L'aquila natural brand is in Wisconsin and I
assume that they,
they make and bottle it and everything there.
Sure.
Are you sure it's from Wisconsin?
Yeah,
that's why.
That's the whole argument for why it's called the Detroit Blah,
blah blah.
Warren Michigan is here,
this distribution distribution.
Right.
But they don't tell you where the spring is located off of.
Let's see.
So we don't know if this is a spring water or a purified water.
So we have no clue.
Gosh,
now we like this beverage.
It's an alternative to soda.
We don't drink sugar.
So it always is not extreme.
Your Shield.
And the problem is when you're,
when you're shutting something down,
I know it's like refreshing,
but you can really taste anything anymore.
But of course when you are shooting down at beverage in general,
like even wines extremely,
the taste of aromas or like disappearing a little bit.
Yeah.
So let's see.
We should bring this on on a little temperature too.
So there's definitely a smell right away.
Yeah,
it's like it has like a blue berries,
fruity smell to it.
Hmm.
Yeah.
It tastes extremely sweet.
[inaudible] extremely sweet though.
It has very tiny bubbles.
You cannot taste water from this.
Right?
There's a artificials and this is for me,
artificial flavors.
Yeah.
You can see it a small home.
Like it's Cleo,
so it's water.
Yeah.
But obviously they are adding some artificial flavors and let's face it,
this is highly processed food.
This is nothing else.
Been highly processed food.
So this is stuff what you're like when you like the big muff from Mcdonald's.
That's might be the water to go.
Oh my God.
Oh,
look into took it there.
Look at their,
their website.
Where does the water originate?
American brand using water source from the U S it's pure fun days when they're
saying this,
that's means it's actually template.
Look at this.
Oh look,
I don't want to say using a triple filtration system.
Here we go.
Yup.
It's crap.
Yeah.
It's stripped of any mineral and this is what I thought.
Now try the Z.
Cause my husband's convinced that he's drinking water when he's drinking.
Zbs going to be even sweeter.
Sorry if he thinks,
if he thinks the sweeteners,
no artificial sweeteners,
no water for sweetness,
but no atrophy of the flavors.
That doesn't,
that doesn't say that.
It doesn't say that
now.
I mean [inaudible] was sweet to him.
Oh No.
Very sweet.
This is another world.
Curious to see what happens.
You look at all the great oxygen,
it looks like I saw it already.
It looks like a soda when you're pouring this now.
Yeah.
It's naturally flavored as a soap in.
It makes you stronger and you're going to feel better.
It's not like Dr Pepper.
Uh,
that's like the smell.
It's like Doc Sherry,
I think of black cherry.
Yeah.
Lecturey it's natural.
It's all natural.
It's all they saying natural flavors.
No artificial stuff in it.
Right.
I apologize.
Yep.
Saying this on camera and radio,
but
it's a good,
it's a good review.
So far he said,
oh Jesus.
Yeah.
Oh,
I agree.
Loves it will give you a case on the way
Pepsi Crystal.
There was a thing.
Whereas it's like,
I need to clean your power or something else.
Yeah,
we should.
I'm paying,
my husband considers this drinking water.
Do you know that when he drinks this he goes,
it's like drinking water.
This is nothing to do with Walter guys.
What is it?
Moded I mean,
I know you don't know.
It's the same word.
I think Pepsi Crystal was crystal was a coke with no color.
This looks like a sorta with no color for me.
Here's why people are
the,
there's no artificial sweeteners,
no sugar,
so people are drinking.
It's become a popular beverage because it's like you're having a soda
experience,
but you're not getting that glucose spike in your sugar.
Disgusting.
Now I don't like them.
I don't drink them.
But always see there's like artificial,
no,
but obviously they need to do something with something to uh,
to put some,
I think it's religious,
like Jesus blesses it or something and then it has a fence.
Whatever.
It's in there.
But I know,
okay,
let's move it along.
That was hilarious.
So we should kind of learn.
It's like a beautiful mountain with no choice.
No,
I know.
So far there's one,
two,
three,
four,
five bottles that I'd never even heard of,
which is so cool.
And there's two more that we haven't yet.
So we have Roy as an fund form
from Slovenia
now.
Yeah,
it's my cousin though.
Video.
Are these,
by the way available at Patina or are these or some of them v She's available to
Hilton is available.
Features available and is skilled is available.
Um,
Roy,
you guys are the only people in the whole United States.
We have a bottle excess,
right?
What?
Nobody else has.
Roy.
This is so exciting when the guy who has access to this room,
I know the the the owner very well here,
also hotel in Slovenia and they found off this,
the spring is extremely old.
I have to be a little careful actually as well.
You should see it because it looks like all,
okay.
When I'm open this,
this really like something going on.
Oh yeah.
Collected at the bottom.
You can see and you know this thing stays like this.
So this is like how it's naturally,
this is natural.
It's wonderful.
You can actually see the flakes.
The men are also at the bottom and it looks like a Sorta as well when I'm
pouring it.
Whoa,
that's cool.
You can see like old residues snow right down here.
What does not happen?
So don't worry guys.
It's all good.
It's all natural.
Hundred percent of that.
Just like z can see like here the bottle,
like what's happening here?
It's crazy.
What is going on now?
Is it that the mineral level is so high that that's what the flakes are?
Yes,
but it's still safe to drink.
Yeah,
that's totally fine.
It's from a spring.
It just cheers.
Cheers.
Here we go.
Oh No.
It just as beautiful as German.
Oh my God.
Oh my goodness.
I love this.
You know,
when I go to Hungary,
I feel like this is the kind of stuff that when you ask for sparkling,
this is what you get.
You get actually,
yeah,
it does.
It is like distinctly the,
the high sodium feels to me European,
but there are something else in that water.
It's not just the sodium.
Very metallic taste to it.
And this water has the highest mechanism content,
whatever been found in a spring water.
Wow.
Um,
what do you think the tds level of softness,
let's recap a little bit.
Fishy 222 a tds is skilled.
It was fun or tds.
He doesn't,
we went back to a 312 Vishy 3050 3000 throwing 5,000 plus 5,000 the price is
right here.
You,
I would go even higher.
Seven because of,
I mean look how active that water is.
The European one,
Huh?
Yeah.
That's mind blowing.
That's just crazy.
But this is again not flied ration anymore so Roy is a water and they're even
marking the like this.
It's not like a water you will drink on a daily basis because it's so loaded
with metals and this is so heavy in your palate as smile.
It's like you cannot drink media.
A lot of this.
I was going to say when it doesn't it don't.
These levels affect how you're tasting food.
The other words when you're drinking a Roy and you're try to taste like food
right next to it.
Forget it.
Yeah.
The food will be tasteless suddenly be called.
This water has sort of overwhelms you.
It is all of the MCO.
Cool thing about Reuters just put a little drops into our oyster and like the
isis really amazing and taste suddenly really it's totally changed and all this
stuff feeling so that's pretty cool.
That's amazing.
This is our water like for a dietary restriction.
That's like we calling it in Europe,
healthy waters in Germany.
They would have a medication label on it.
They would,
yes.
It's considered to be a health water.
Why?
We have different regulations in Germany and this is I think where the American
market really needs to step up their game a little bit when it comes to bottled
water.
There regulations are very strict when it comes to a bottled water in Germany
and the labeling as well.
Even in the government is saying like by some borders of,
there's a brand from core core that's called [inaudible] and [inaudible] spelled
in a regular basis.
Aquifer,
a cure UAA phone.
And they said like the German government,
no wait a minute.
That's like purified water up on our Cummins.
Good water.
You cannot label this fight.
So they misspelled for a Q a on purpose that they can label [inaudible].
Wow.
The regulations are very strict now,
but I think it's good.
I want to,
for the person listening or watching this,
how can they,
this is like an obviously intriguing topic.
Learn more like is it,
should they go to your site?
Like what do you recommend to go to my site?
You can,
you can come to Patina obviously.
Yeah.
So what it tells,
what happened is that Patina on a daily basis.
And we have this beautiful water menu.
What I brought a swollen
over here.
So this is the Patina water menu.
We have 20 different mineral waters and every water has like two pages and you
can literally like see a little taste profile off that water,
a story of the water,
the tds countries,
then actually what's in there and then a price.
So,
and this goes like to 20 different mineral waters.
What we are offering right now,
this is incredible.
Um,
Dana Lee's coming up in July.
We will have a water tasting based on our,
based on our,
uh,
Dyno Amen Menu at Swan.
So three different waters paired to your dishes.
Is the Roy the Slovenian?
Yeah,
this is the tricky part.
So Roy,
you kind of access in America,
but retail would be around $25.
Okay.
What is this last one here that we see from Hungary?
From Hungary.
So is there like hatred and contempt?
How do they put that in a bottle last?
That will be amazing.
And we shouldn't.
We should all get a new class.
This is,
this is a special line dancing.
Very special again,
thank you so much.
Thank you sir.
I like the Roy.
I really liked this.
Roy is actually pretty cool and I have this sometimes in water tastings as well.
What I do and people always stick to Roy.
They always like,
that's a really cool water.
I think it's so unique that they're saying like,
I really loved that water.
It's a,
it's like the level of the bubbliness.
I liked the sodium content.
I feel,
I don't know.
It's a got a lot of pizzazz.
Yeah.
The queen likes a dollar a sparkling water.
Interesting English.
Yeah.
Let's see.
The Hungarians is a still water again and again,
so we going but it has a little,
a little middle content.
You okay?
I see that's called mirror from Hungaria
and let's,
let's just,
let's taste this.
I get a shit about it then post it again.
Okay.
Let's see.
That is,
Whoa,
horrible.
That is terrible.
What is going on?
I even think that as well is it is a water water
that is garbage.
What is that terrible
little sulfur [inaudible] 7,500 milligrams of sulfur.
Let me see that.
Can I see the bottle?
This is their bottled water,
like ice tea,
DSL before you'll see the tds level GDS level.
It's got eight thousand eight thousand and higher.
10 I'll go 1616 tds.
But in Hungary we have Dev,
a lot of springs and mineral.
You want answered the meal?
A convenient store.
Like I want to get a bottle of water.
Like you're just visiting.
You grabbed that off the shelf and then you're getting a hot to take you buck.
So that's the reason they getting guys.
Walter,
it's not just water.
Water has taste and even here I know a lot of purified waters.
Again,
filling everything out of there.
They creating Shiming boys that everybody thinks it's all tastes the same.
Yeah,
they all taste the same.
You will see now here,
that's what my,
what I brought.
Suddenly you realize,
Holy Shit,
what does taste good advice.
I've never seen this one on the shelf.
It was disgusting.
I was not.
You're jr this is upsetting water.
But I mean and when I go to,
when I'm in Budapest I always order [inaudible] which is sparkling water and
they definitely don't bring that shit.
They bring their,
they bring stuff similar to,
I would say the Spanish one,
but
to recap table one of the things too like to basic like advance yourself in this
nasty ass for springwater glacier water or what?
Correct.
Mineral Water,
mineral water will say it's on the bottle and it's this.
This is really the key guys.
Always when you're going to the grocery store and do it with your kids,
do it with your family.
It's kind of like buy several bottles of water but make sure they are all coming
from a natural resource could then they will taste differently and have them
side by side.
Do not slow them down,
have them side by side in different classes and really taste them through and
it's not able to realize holy shit,
water has taste does and it's from Earth.
I mean you think about it,
it's coming to mother earth.
We should be thankful that we can drink all this kind of cool different waters
that we have access to clean water.
We're going to get blue band some of that.
And let's face it as well.
There are millions of people who don't have x access to clean water.
This is a big topic for me as far as the water some again,
um,
because everybody knows I have like so many different cool Walters and some
people are saying I'm the most hydrated person on this planet,
but there's billions of people or millions of people who don't have access.
And I think we should all honored that we have access to clean water and we
should help people who don't have access or water.org for example,
I'm supporting the Matt Damon Foundation and I'm trying to raise money or the
time to,
to help other countries.
Is that him?
Is that his water.org?
Yes sir.
The Matt Damon,
I think.
Yeah,
cause he's big on that.
Right.
And I think it's a great thing what he's doing there and I'm supporting them.
Even on the home page,
there's a link that you can spend some money and I think it's a good thing to
do.
This is quest.
Super Cool.
This was the most mind blowing thing I,
you know,
you think of,
but you don't think about water.
I mean,
I mean I don't,
I just consume it.
Consume it.
Yeah.
This was outstanding in California.
We had for the last five years a big drought.
Finally,
we are out of the drought.
Right.
But I think that doesn't mean we can waste water again.
So this is the point of swell.
But I like to do with my water menu.
I want to give water a value that people understand.
Hey,
this a little bit more than,
than just water.
Yeah.
And maybe I could start to rethink my use of water as well.
And maybe when I'm washing my teeth don't have the tab open the whole time.
Just clause it.
Even California is not in a drought right now.
Yeah.
But still we need to save water because the summer is coming.
Trust me in two years.
We are back on throughout this very big drought problem again.
We have to save water for the future generations and therefore let's all drink
enough water.
That's the key guys do.
I don't drink sodas,
drinking of water,
but please be considered as well what you're doing with water.
Yeah.
Very good.
Um,
Martin Reesie,
Risa,
how do you see a giant person that's kind of,
I dunno,
what do you say?
R.
I.
E.
S.
O that way e.
See,
yeah,
I know our website is a Martin Hyphen reset,
right?
[inaudible] dot com you can go to Patina,
uh,
in downtown Los Angeles and actually see Martin in the flesh and a experience
the water menu.
And I'm actually,
you know,
I think this is really cool to try out different waters and,
and,
and see if you guys can experience some of what we did here today.
It's a very,
very eyeopening thing.
You can take a class from Martin.
He can,
that's what I'm saying.
You can take classes.
Yeah,
call me up.
Shoot me an email.
I'm always habitual hydrate people.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you.
So thanks so much for coming.
I know that was cool.
Very cool.
This is a h two flow signing off and uh,
I got a,
I got a song for us,
so let me see what he paid.
He saying,
not the water Jamey and Kinda the Vasa [inaudible].
This is nick.
Nick,
Nick Tya dare nine does not Dossie sexual listening.
Guys,
we'll see you on the next one.
Alright,
here we go.
I'm going over the new bridge.
Three years.
Here we
go.
It'd be like 20 like 20.